die deutsche China Politik aus dem
Plenum des Deutschen Bundestages meldet
sich jetzt mein Kollege Erhard Schäfer
und mit dem Ende der Fragestunde und da
sind wir meine Damen und Herren genau
zur richtigen Sekunde zurück im
Deutschen Bundestag den
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin ruft in dieser
Sekunde das haben wir auch schon lange
nicht mehr so schön präzise getroffen
die Aktuelle Stunde auf die hier
stattfinden wird auf Antrag der
Koalitionsfraktionen und die den Titel
trägt Proteste in China und deutsche
China Politik Hans Werner hat einige
entscheidende Punkte eben schon
angesprochen die Proteste in China
dauern an in einzelnen Regionen scheinen
sie auch zu eskalieren die staatsmachte
zeigt sich von ihrer oder versucht es
zumindest von ihrer stärksten Seite zu
zeigen das ist die eine Medaille oder
die eine Seite der Medaille das andere
ist eine China Strategie an der die
Bundesregierung arbeitet und die in
diesen Tagen und Wochen entstehen soll
und deswegen steigen wir jetzt ganz fix
in diese Debatte hier ein Jürgen Trittin
ist der erste Redner außenpolitischer
Sprecher der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
nächstes das Symbol jener mutigen
Chinesinnen und Chinesen die sich nicht
mit der
repressiven-politik von Ski weiter
abfinden wollen ich finde dieser Mut
dieses Selbstbewusstsein das verdient
unser Unterstützung unserer Respekt
kurz nach dem
pompösen 20 Parteitag
schichinas offensichtlich vor allem
riesigen Legitimationsproblem denn es
gab Vorboten für diese Demonstration da
gab es jene Shanghai Nachbarn die
losgezogen sind nachdem sie monatelang
eingesperrt waren ohne Essen ihre
benachbarte kp-zelle zu verprügeln da
gab es jene Arbeiterinnen und Arbeiter
die nachdem sie ja wochenlang bei Fox
kommen dem Apple fertiger in der Fabrik
gefangen waren und produzieren mussten
in den Streik getreten sind und dafür
von Sicherheitskräften angegriffen
worden ja
die KP hat mit leichten Lockerungen vor
kurzem der Zeit darauf gearbeitet aber
dieses beseitigt nicht die Ursache der
Unzufriedenheit denn die liegt viel
tiefer wir müssen heute feststellen
Chinas zerocover Politik ist gescheitert
es sind zu wenige Menschen geimpft und
gegen Omicron hilft eben es nicht weg zu
sperren und lockdowns zu machen
und
die corona-krise ist ja nicht das
einzige Problem in China ist eine
riesige immobilienbase geplatzt das
heißt Millionen Menschen drohen um ihr
Erspartes gebracht zu werden weil die
Wohnung für die Sie bezahlt haben nicht
gebaut werden inzwischen sind einige
dazu übergegangen ihre eigenen Wohnung
zu besetzen die nicht fertig gebaut sind
und die Folgen für China sind
Millionen WanderarbeiterInnen und
Wanderarbeiter sind arbeitslos geworden
und zurück in ihre Dörfer vertrieben
worden ein Fünftel der Jugendlichen
hofft hochqualifiziert im Ausland
studiert sind arbeitslos
und die Lieferketten sind und bleiben
gestört china hat das geringste Wachstum
in Asien Schlusslicht geworden mit
verheerenden Folgen auch für unsere
Wirtschaft denn die Lieferketten bleiben
gestört und in dieser Sackgasse
beschließt die chinesische Führung nicht
zu ändern sondern Vollgas zu geben
dagegen wird zu Recht auf begehrt und
dagegen brauchen wir eine neue
China-Politik selbstverständlich wir in
Europa können nicht ohne China aber wir
sollten gerade vor dem Hintergrund
dieser Vorgänger auch ganz ruhig
feststellen China kann auch nicht ohne
Europa ja eine stimmt das alte Dogma ob
man das nun Schröder oder Merkel
zuschreibt Wandel durch Handel ist halt
gescheitert
aber wir müssen uns klarmachen und zwar
nicht nur der Staat auch die Wirtschaft
dass Chinas Markt auf Dauer eben kein
verlässlicher Markt mehr ist das müssen
wir in unserer Strategie berücksichtigen
deswegen müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
wir souveräner dass wir resilienter
werden deswegen ist es klug wenn viele
Unternehmen sagen wir wollen
diversifizieren wir wollen auch
Produktion zurückverlagern wir werden
selber dafür auch Geld in die Hand
nehmen müssen weil wir in Europa Chips
Produktion brauchen weil wir
rückverlagern müssen Pharma weil wir
rückverlagern müssen auch die
Photovoltaikindustrie die mal eine
schwarz-gelbe Regierung nach China
vertrieben hat
aber es ist dann eben auch unklug die
eigene Abhängigkeit von China dadurch zu
erhöhen wie es vier große Unternehmen
gemacht haben die dafür alleine
verantwortlich sind dass die deutschen
Direktinvestitionen in China mitten in
der corona-krise gestiegen sind es ist
nicht klug auch wenn man Schwierigkeiten
hat zu diversifizieren die eigene
Abhängigkeit noch weiter zu vergrößern
und das ist der Grund warum diese
Regierung gesagt hat ihr tut das künftig
auf eigene Rechnung diese Investitionen
die garantieren wir euch nicht mehr wenn
ihr sie beispielsweise in Shinji
antidete das tut ihr auf eigene Rechnung
und ich finde so geht eine
menschenrechtsbasierte
Außenwirtschaftspolitik
und schließlich
wir brauchen ein lieferkettengesetz wir
brauchen ein gesetzliches Verbot für den
Import von Produkten aus Zwangsarbeit
das muss unsere Antwort auf tgenpings
angedrohte Repressionswelle sein und ich
will mal eine Bemerkung noch dazu machen
wer denn unbedingt
unter in den Weihnachtsbaum
ein neues iPhone aus der Fabrik von Fox
con haben möchte
dann sage ich auch
Apple ist der Konzern
der dieser Tage seine erdrop-funktion
für China eingeschränkt hat
mit dieser erdrop-funktion konnten
Menschen Inhalte beispielsweise Videos
von Demonstrationen in öffentlichen
Verkehrsmitteln an andere weitergeben
diese Einschränkung gibt es nur in China
ich sage Ihnen
wer über den chinesischen Polizeistaat
schimpft der darf von Apple in diesem
Zusammenhang nicht schweigen
ist der außenpolitische Sprecher der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen und hat
die aktuelle Stunde zur Lage in China
und zur deutschen China Politik eröffnet
fünf Minuten Redezeit das ist das
Konzept der Aktuellen Stunde und die hat
jetzt Johann wadeful an der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
Unionsfraktion in China miteinander
diskutieren weiß jetzt nicht ganz
Bewusstseinswandel bei der
Ampelkoalition der Grund dafür ist oder
mehr der taktische hintergrund ist dass
man die Aktuelle Stunde zu ihrer
Einbürgerungspolitik die wir beantragt
haben auf den morgigen Tag vertragen
wollte aber wie immer auch sei wir
nehmen das Angebot wahr und diskutieren
Herr Kollege die mit ihm gern wieder
über eine China Politik natürlich auch
vor dem Hintergrund dieser
bemerkenswerten Proteste die sie ein
Kind beschrieben haben und die ja in
einem wirklich
frappierenden Gegensatz zu den
Entscheidungen der KP China stehen die
gerade sozusagen einige Tage zuvor für
einen Machtzuwachs in der Person von
Präsident schieb gesorgt haben wie wir
denen seit Mao zedron in diesem Land
nicht gesehen haben und das dennoch
dieses Regime auf tönern in den Füßen
steht das haben die Proteste gezeigt und
sie da will ich Ihnen noch gar nicht
widersprechen der Kollege Trittin haben
das gerade eben noch einmal
nachgezeichnet das zeigt dieses Regime
ist vulnerabel zumindestens für einen
Moment und das bedeutet dass wir uns
positionieren können und müssen und dass
wir dazu auch eine Möglichkeit zum
Einwirken haben
voraussetzung dafür ist nur meine sehr
verehrten Kolleginnen und Kollegen dass
wir und das ist der Titel auch ihre
aktuellen Stunde dass wir eine
kohärente China Politik der
Bundesregierung haben und die sehen wir
nicht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
denn die Rede Herr Kollege Trittin die
sie hier gehalten haben die Würde der
Bundeskanzler hier nie so halten der
steht offensichtlich für eine ganz
andere China-Politik
das hat seine Reise noch mal sehr
eindrücklich gezeigt eine Reise der
verpassten Chancen eine Reise des weiter
so würde man in ihrem Sinne sagen eine
Reise des Business as usual und das muss
ich an der Situation schon sagen wer in
der jetzigen Situation verkennt
das China sich massiv verändert dass
China sich immer mehr von einem
autoritären zu einem diktatorischen
System wandelt was internationale Regeln
nicht achtet sondern eine sinozentrische
Weltordnung errichten will und das
Deutschland sich gemeinsam mit
europäischen Partnern dazu positionieren
muss der erkennt die Zeichen der Zeit
nicht und das gilt für den Bundeskanzler
und insofern war
bemerkenswert die Kritik der
bundesaußenministerin die gesagt hat der
Bundeskanzler hat den Zeitpunkt der
Reise entschieden jetzt ist entscheidend
sein entscheiden die Botschaften die wir
gemeinsam festgelegt haben im
Koalitionsvertrag die Botschaften die
auch ich hier mit nach Zentralasien
gebracht habe um auch die in China
deutlich zu machen so Annalena bärburg
davon von all den Botschaften hat der
Bundeskanzler überhaupt gar nichts
gesagt und das merkt man dann auch sehr
konkret in der Politik die diese
Bundesregierung macht Herr Kollege
Trittin das was sie gerade eben
angemahnt haben das geschieht eben alles
nicht das zurück verlagern das haben sie
gefordert das unabhängig machen nein man
geht tiefer in einer Abhängigkeit von
China rein und das hat keine
Entscheidung so deutlich gemacht wie die
Entscheidung dass man Costco einen
Beteiligung wenn auch eine
Minderheitsbeteiligung aber eine
Beteiligung an kritischer Infrastruktur
im Hamburger Hafen zugelassen hat und
Frau stark Watzinger die
bundesforschungsminister dann hat das
kritisiert und hat gesagt das darf man
nicht machen und um mit nuripur von den
Grünen hat gesagt das darf man nicht
machen und dennoch hat der Bundeskanzler
das gemacht und meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren das zeigt am Ende das
ist genauso wie bei den
Panzerlieferungen nach in die Ukraine
die nicht stattfinden am Ende spielen
Grüne und FDP in der Außenpolitik der
Musik Deutschland keine Rolle der
Bundeskanzler entscheidet das alleine
und er macht verkehrte Außenpolitik an
dieser Stelle liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und da muss ich weil ich die
geschätzte Kollege Jansen hier auch sehe
die ja gemeinsam mit der FDP-Fraktion in
der letzten Legislaturperiode Graf
Lamsdorf wird das auch entsinnen Wert
darauf gelegt hat dass wir gegenüber
China eine klare Politik machen und
sogar gefordert hat dass der EU China
Gipfel abgesagt wird so sind sie
aufgetreten das hat ihr parteivorsister
Christian Lindner gefragt und haben sie
in der Bundesregierung jeden Anspruch
aufgegeben mit einem Kabinettsposten
internationale Politik zu machen und da
sieht man jetzt eben auch ganz praktisch
von ihrem Anspruch eine deutliche
China-Politik zu machen die dieser die
diese Kritik
rüberbringt und in deutsche Politik
übersetzt ist nichts übrig geblieben und
deswegen es gibt jeden Anlass eine
kohärente deutsche China-Politik zu
formulieren die deutlich macht das ist
ein systemischer Rivale dem wir uns
gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
Partnern entgegenstellen vielen Dank
Johann badepfuhl einer der Chef
vertretenden Vorsitzenden der
cdu/csu-fraktion im Deutschen Bundestag
und es folgt einer der stellvertretenden
Vorsitzenden der SPD-Fraktion im
Deutschen Bundestag nämlich in Dagmar
Schmidt und wir sind immer noch in der
Aktuellen Stunde zur Lage in China
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich wünschte es
gäbe heute ein schöneren Grund um über
China zu reden aber es ist gut dass wir
das tun um unsere Solidarität mit den
Protestierenden und unser Mitgefühl mit
den vielen Menschen die unter den
radikalen Maßnahmen leiden zum Ausdruck
zu bringen am vergangenen Wochenende
haben so viele Menschen in China
protestiert wie seit 1989 nicht mehr sie
protestieren gegen eine
corona-politik die keine Exit-Strategie
hat die die Menschen einsperrt überwacht
drangsaliert und immer öfter zu Elend
und Tod führt weil die Grundversorgung
mit Nahrung weil medizinische Hilfe und
persönlicher Kontakt fehlen weil Arbeit
und Einkommen nicht mehr gesichert sind
bei Menschen in ihren Fabriken Wohnungen
oder Universitäten festsetzen weil
Schulen geschlossen Kinder von ihren
Eltern getrennt werden und weil der
versperrte Weg zum Krankenhaus oder der
versperrte Weg der Feuerwehr kostet
wir fühlen mit Ihnen und stehen an ihrer
Seite
schon früh zu Beginn der corona-pandemie
wurde die Systemfrage gestellt und
diskutiert kann eine Demokratie oder
kann eine Autokratie besser mit einer
solchen Pandemie umgehen in China wurden
nachdem das Virus nicht mehr zu leugnen
war rigorosem Maßnahmen ergriffen selbst
die WHO attestierte seiner Zeit dass
diese eindämmungsmaßnahmen in China
effektiv sein und im Lande erzählte man
wie erfolgreich die eigene Strategie im
Vergleich zu denen im Westen sei wo man
im Chaos versinke und gleichzeitig
verschärfte die Regierung Kontrollen und
Überwachung und an der
überlegenheitsstrategie der nullkovic
und der
gegenheitsüberlegenheitserzählung der
nullkovic-strategie wurde auch noch
festgehalten als man feststellen musste
dass das Virus mutiert und die
ansteckendere ommikon Variante neue
Herausforderungen hat als man
feststellen musste dass die eigenen
Impfstoffe schlechter vor schweren
Krankheitsverläufen schützen als die
mrna-impfstoffe und dass die
Priorisierung der Impfkampagne die
unserer Stadt ältere adressierte falsch
und die impflücke zu groß ist und das
Gesundheitssystem vor Überlastung zu
schützen man hat den Ausstieg aus der
nullkovic-strategie verpasst weil sie
eben längst keine Strategie mehr war
sondern ein Dogma
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Deutschland hat eines der besten
Gesundheitssysteme der Welt und dennoch
haben auch wir erlebt wie schwierig die
pandemische Situation zu beherrschen ist
dass auch wir nicht immer wissen konnten
was genau geschehen wird und was der
beste Umgang mit der Pandemie ist aber
wir haben das Privileg in einer
Demokratie zu leben alle können offen
ihre Meinung sagen können gegen das
Impfen protestieren und auch die Straße
gehen all das hält eine funktionierende
Demokratie aus doch gleichzeitig
diskutieren wir Probleme
wissensorientiert und lösen Sie wir
diskutieren wegen ab korrigieren Fehler
und passen unsere Politik an wenn es
neue Erkenntnisse oder sich verändernde
lagen gibt seines Mutationen
Fortschritte beim Impfen und neue
Medikamente wir waren und sind weiß Gott
nicht immer einer Meinung aber
Wissenschaft und Politik haben
argumentiert diskutiert Studien gewählt
gute Kompromisse gefunden und damit
offen und nachvollziehbar gehandelt wir
haben zusammengehalten
darauf können wir stolz sein
noch ist die Pandemie nicht
vorbei den
nach wie vor Scheidung aber während wir
uns hierzulande auf den Weg in die
Normalität machen steht China noch vor
grundsätzlichen Entscheidungen China
steckt in einem Dilemma drei Jahre
nullkovic-strategie haben eine relativ
geringe Zahl von Todesfällen und
Infektionen gebracht aber zu hohen
Kosten und ein Weg hin zur Normalität
ist noch nicht in Sicht China selbst hat
21 Punkteplan vorgestellt mit dem die
corona-politik angepasst werden soll und
vieles darin wie die neue impfstrategie
ist richtig es ist im Kern aber eine
Abkehr von der nullkovic-strategie und
die Umsetzung daher offen und noch
fragwürdig viele hatten aber in China
gehofft dass ich nach dem Parteitag
etwas ändert weiterhin verfolgen die
Behörden jedoch ihre Hosen Maßnahmen und
ein Ende ist immer noch nicht in Sicht
das führt in einem ohnehin pandemieten
Volk zu zusätzliche Verunsicherung und
Wut und die Überlegenheit
die Erzählung der chinesischen
nullkowitsch-strategie funktioniert
nicht mehr wir können ermessen wie
unerträglich die Situation für viele
Menschen in China sein muss so
unerträglich dass sie trotz der Gefahren
protestieren und damit ihre Freiheit
ihre Gesundheit und ihr Leben riskieren
diese Ereignisse in China dürfen uns
nicht unberührt lassen wir hoffen auf
kluge Entscheidungen auf einen
friedlichen Umgang mit dem friedlichen
Protest und einen Weg zu mehr Freiheit
für die Menschen in China
aus der SPD-Fraktion wo sie eine der
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitzenden
ist in der Debatte nicht nur über die
Lage in China sondern auch zur deutschen
China Politik sie wissen dass an einer
China Strategie gearbeitet wird in der
Bundesregierung und in dieser Debatte
jetzt Jürgen braun
menschenrechtspolitischer Sprecher der
afd-fraktion völlig gesunde Bürger
werden unter anderem drakonischer
Strafmaßnahmen eingeschüchtert oder den
Beifall der Staatsmedien werden
Wasserwerfer gegen friedliche
Demonstranten eingesetzt bei
Demonstrationsteilnehmer werden
Hausdurchsuchung vorgenommen Handys
beschlagnahmt im Internet Zensur und
Einschränkungen der Meinungsfreiheit die
Menschenrechtslage so verheerend dass
sich die UNO einschaltet
das ist nicht nur die gegenwärtige Lage
in der Volksrepublik China das war bis
letztes Jahr auch Teil der Lage in
Deutschland
die Bundesregierungen haben sich selbst
so verhalten wie es die Kommunistische
Partei Chinas nach wie vor tut
auch hier bei uns Besuch von Verwandten
in einem anderen Bundesland verboten
allein auf einer Parkbank ein Buch lesen
verboten Schlittenfahren mit der Familie
in der frischen an der frischen Luft
verboten die unsanten gefördert sie
beklagen sich jetzt zu Recht über Zensur
in China aber was haben sie selbst bis
vor kurzem gefördert im Staatsfernsehen
tagtäglich Beschallung mit irrelevanten
zahlen die nur ein Ziel hatten die
Verbreitung von Angst wie beim televisor
aus Orwells 1984 zeitgleich wurden
Kritiker dieser Zustände diffamiert und
bekämpft freiheitsliebende Spaziergänger
als Alu Hüte und Rechtsextremisten
beschimpft und das Restaurant schwimmen
wir dann und Fitnessstudios verbannt mit
anderen von bürgerhaft und Rentenkürzung
ein SPD Oberbürgermeister bei Stuttgart
erlaubte gab Schusswaffen gegen
Spaziergänger einzusetzen
Polizeigewalt in Deutschland so massiv
wie seit über 30 Jahren seit dem Ende
des SED-Regimes nicht mehr so massiv
dass sich der UNO Sonderberichterstatter
für Folter einschaltete
Polizeigewalt wie wir sie zu Recht in
China beklagen auch hier bei uns und
nahezu nahezu alle von ihnen haben
mitgemacht Herr Trittin sie haben die
Impfpflicht für alle gefordert jetzt
können Sie viel über Freiheit in China
reden Lauterbach ist ja passenderweise
gar nicht da wogegen sich jetzt mutige
Chinesen wenden wurde hier jahrelang
praktiziert die totalitäre Zero Kurve
Petition die wurde von den führenden
Figuren des Mainstreams unterzeichnet
sirokon wird klima-hüpferin Luisa
Neubauer die staatsfinanz der
staatsfinanzierte Georg Reste sogar der
vom Stasi Mann zum Berliner
Staatssekretär aufgestiegene andere Holm
war mit von der Partie auch Sebastian
Drosten hat in der Fachzeitschrift zur
Lenze hören sie zu Herr lambsdorf die
Wahrheit wollen sie nicht hören das weiß
ich ist mir klar ja in der
Fachzeitschriften
los während der Bürger aufgerufen ich
bitte zum Thema der
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach erst das
ist chinesische Null cover-ideologie in
reihenform jetzt will der politisch
mediale Komplex all das plötzlich
vergessen machen angesichts der
brutalunterdrückten Proteste in China an
diesem Wochenende lügen sich deutsche
Staatsmedien mal wieder im Kopf und
Kragen der Tagesschau heißt es ich
zitiere große im Kampagnen gibt es in
diesem Land mit 1,4 Milliarden
Einwohnern nicht stattdessen leben die
Menschen in China seit knapp drei Jahren
mit immer wiederkehrenden lockdowns
Massentest Ausgangs und
reisebeschränkung Zitat Ende dabei hat
die Volksrepublik China eine Impfquote
von
89%. eine der höchsten der Welt aber
keine noch so hohe Impfquote hat zum
Einknicken der deutschen Regierung in
Sachen Null covid geführt nein es waren
hartnäckige Bürgerproteste und
Bürgerproteste allein den wir das zu
verstanden haben die chinesische
Strategie die chinesische Strategie der
Einschüchterung und Einsperrung die hier
und heute zu rechteinhellig verurteilt
wird war deutsche
staats-saison geblieben wenn nicht die
wahre Zivilgesellschaft aufgestanden
wird wäre über ganz Deutschland verteilt
friedliche Spaziergänge und dieser
skandalösenpolitik endlich Einhalt zu
gebieten
zur Verteidigung der jetzigen Regierung
ist zu sagen dass sie auch nur
weitergeführt hat was schon unter der
Merkel Regierung begonnen hatte in den
Expertenrat des Innenministeriums berief
sie einen Mann der nicht nur erklärter
Fan von Mao Zedong ist sondern auch Geld
von der Kommunistischen Partei Chinas
bekam der linguistel war der Verfasser
des propagandistischen angstpapiers
unter dem verräterischen Titel von Wuhan
lernen ausgerechnet wo Hahn wo das neue
Corona-Virus entstanden ist ich sage
Ihnen was man von Wuhan lernen kann wie
man ein Virus gentechnisch so
manipuliert dass es hochvirulent wird
und man damit eine weltweite Massenpanik
auslösen kann sie wollten auch noch das
chinesische Gesellschaftsmodell
imitieren aber der deutsche Sonderweg
gelang Gott sei Dank zu einem Ende wenn
jetzt noch die maskenpflicht komplett
fällt dann haben wir endlich unsere
Freiheit wieder und das wünsche ich auch
den mutigen Menschen in China
Jürgen braun aus der afd-fraktion mit
seiner Sicht auf die Dinge in einer
Debatte des Deutschen Bundestages zur
Lage in China und zur deutschen China
Politik mehr dazu jetzt von Alexander
Graf Lambsdorff aus der FDP-Fraktion da
ist der stellvertretender Vorsitzender
hier war so ein leichter schwefelduft
ich musste den vertreiben
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wir alle sehen die Bilder aus China
Demonstranten mit weißen Blättern wir
sehen die Ausbrüche aus den
abgeriegelten Wohnviertel wir hören und
das ist wirklich eine neue Qualität auch
die politischen Forderungen der
Demonstranten und Demonstranten nun da
ist es so dass in der China Daily dem
Blatt der Kommunistischen Partei
kürzlich zu lesen war und ich zitiere
die Unannehmlichkeiten der Bevölkerung
im Kampf gegen das Virus sollten im
Kontext eines größeren Bildes betrachtet
werden meine Damen und Herren lassen Sie
mich kurz dieses größere Bild skizzieren
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam betrachten
wovon China Daily spricht nach dem
Schulterschluss miteinander angegriffen
Chinas Droge werden gegenüber Taiwan
waren nie so offensiv wie in diesem Jahr
im Iran warfen Tausende von Frauen
Demonstrationen das gesamte Land wo
stehen wir also heute im November
22 im Kontext eines größeren Bildes
Putin sieht sich schweren
innenpolitischen Verwerfungen gegenüber
einer massiven internationalen Isolation
und eine militäre strategischen
Fehlschlag das mularegime im Iran
bekämpft den Aufstand an der breiten
iranischen Öffentlichkeit der sich an
der Brutalität des Regimes entzündet hat
und chising Ping erntet die Früchte
seiner corona-politik das Volk hat nach
Jahren eine exzessiven repressiven
zero-kovic-strategie zurückgeschlagen
und verbindet dies mit politischen
Forderungen wer wollte ihnen das
verdenken totale lockdowns über mehr als
zwei Monate eingesperrte Menschen ohne
genug zu essen kranke Kinder die von
ihren Eltern getrennt wurden ganze
Wohnviertel die abgesperrt wurden
staatliche desinfektionskampagnen in
Abertausenden von Privatwohnungen Zahl
und Intensität der staatlichen Willkür
Eingriffe in China sind genauso
erschreckend wie die hartnäckige
Steigerung der macht aber in Peking
endlich westliche Impfstoffe ins Land zu
lassen diese aber braucht es wenn das
Land über die nächsten Monate zu einem
Anschein von Normalität zurückkehren
will stattdessen beharrt die Führung der
Kommunistischen Partei auf sinowack eine
minderwertigen Impfstoff für den die
Impfquote vollkommen unerheblich ist
meine Damen und Herren
noch einmal der Kontext eines größeren
Bildes am Ende dieses Jahres zeigt sich
über deutlich das nationalistische
islamistische und kommunistische
Diktaturen scheitern sie scheitern an
ihrem Anspruch ihren Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern ein besseres Leben in Freiheit
Wohlstand und würde zu garantieren als
wir von Ihnen so oft geschmähte und
angeblich verachtete Westen aber
Verhalten der Menschen in exakt diesen
Ländern in diesen Diktaturen sieht man
die verlogen die Politik der macht aber
in Wahrheit ist die Demonstranten wollen
ihren Landsleuten nicht etwa eine
westliche Lebensweise aufzwingen es hat
mit West und Osten Nord- und überhaupt
nichts zu tun nein was wir im Kontext
des größeren Bildes sehen
das ist die ureigene Sehnsucht des
Menschen nach einem Leben in Freiheit
und Würde und das ist eine Sehnsucht die
auch die Menschen in China haben frei
reisen frei Glauben frei lieben
paradoxerweise sind die universellen
Menschenrechte die ja gerade deswegen so
erfolgreich so wirkmächtig weil sie in
höchstem Maße individuell sind aber es
zählen auch dazu frei publizieren frei
demonstrieren und frei wählen in der
Geschichte der Menschheit gibt es kein
Gesellschaftsmodell dass die
unverletzbarkeit der menschlichen Würde
in so hohem Maß gewährleistet wie die
freiheitliche Demokratie und der
vielleicht wichtigste Unterschied
zwischen den Liberalen und den
illiberalen Gesellschaft besteht darin
das erste Kritik zulassen und letztere
sie mit allen Mitteln zu unterdrücken
suchen das Jahr 2022 hat uns diesen
Unterschied auf mannigfaltige Weise
gezeigt eben zuletzt in China und viele
die in Russland im Iran oder auch in
China auf Missstände Hinweisen riskieren
damit lange Haftstrafen
umerziehungslage oder unterschreiben
sogar ihr Todesurteil ihr Mut meine
Damen und Herren ihr Mut ist uns
Beispiel wir verneigen uns vor Ihnen wir
verneigen uns vor den Menschen die sich
für Freiheit Menschenrechte Demokratie
und Rechtsstaat einsetzen im Iran in
Russland und jetzt auch in China von
herzlichen Dank
Alex
Folgen seven
Sprecherin für internationale Politik in
der Linksfraktion und es geht weiter um
China und die deutsche China Politik
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
gegen repressive covid-maßnahmen zu
demonstrieren ist ein Menschenrecht
unabhängig davon ob es in China Kanada
Deutschland oder anderswo in der Welt
ausgeübt wird
wer aber die wer aber die Universalität
der Menschenrechte verteidigt der darf
nicht in unterschiedlichen Ländern
völlig andere Maßstäbe gelten lassen und
für ihr herangehen gilt im besonderen
Maße der Satz aus der Bergpredigt ich
zitiere warum siehst du den Splitter im
Auge deines Bruders aber dem Balken in
deinem Auge bemerkst du nicht Matthäus 7
Absatz 30 Tage Ende denn eines geht
nicht meine Damen und Herren hier in
Deutschland noch lockdowns
Ausgangssperren Schulschließungen
impfpflichten zu rufen und die Proteste
dagegen
unisono als rechts oder covidioten oder
als schwurbler zu denunzieren und alle
diejenigen die in China gegen die
Maßnahmen der zero-
als Freiheitskämpfer zu erheben
und ich hoffe dass Ihnen dass irgendwann
irgendwann auffallen wird denn sie haben
bereits jetzt international mit ihren
doppelten Standards was die
Glaubwürdigkeit der deutschen Politik
insgesamt angeht schweren Schaden
angerichtet vom wirtschaftlichen Abstieg
begleitet für den allein diese
Bundesregierung die Verantwortung trägt
ist Deutschland dabei in einem ganz
anderen Bereich eine Spitzenposition zur
erobern im Bereich der Moral oder
genauer gesagt im Bereich der
Doppelmoral und ich kann nur warnen
davor diese Doppelmoral auch in punkto
China anzulegen und ich möchte Ihnen
auch Beispiele ihrer doppelbereich geben
heute morgen im Auswärtigen Ausschuss
haben wir die Bundesregierung gefragt ob
sie den Angriff des nato-partners Türkei
auch Syrien als Völkerrechtsbruch
ansieht diese Bundesregierung hat
gehandelt dass sie die Bombardierungen
der Türkei der völkerrechtlich nicht
bewerten kann es fehlten ihr genügend
Hinweise für diese Bewertung und wissen
Sie was noch dazu kommt das Auswärtige
Amt konnte am Vormittag ja noch nicht
einmal beantworten wie die
Bundesregierung den Krieg der USA und
der Koalition der Willigen 2003 gegen
den irakvölkerrechtlich bewertet und
will die Antwort nachreichen und wir
sind gespannt ob auch hier weil es sich
um einen Nato-Partner handelt der
Bundesregierung selbst 19 Jahre nach dem
us-angriffskrieg nicht genügend Hinweise
vorliegen um eine völkerrechtliche
Bewertung vorzunehmen ich hoffe sie
warten nicht darauf dass diese
vermeintlichen Massen Vernichtungswaffen
im Irak noch irgendwie gefunden werden
damit sie uns anwirken können
international kommen Sie mit diesen
Nebelkerzen meine Damen und Herren nicht
durch wer lediglich weltmeisterlich bei
der Doppelmoral ist der verspielt jede
Glaubwürdigkeit um global für
Menschenrechte und die Einhaltung des
Völkerrechtes einzustehen und ich will
Ihnen noch ein Beispiel geben
Qatar auf der einen Seite legen sie sich
die Regenbogen
Arten dann sollte liefern sie Waffen an
dieses Land und schließen einen Deal
über die Lieferung von Flüssiggas ab auf
der einen Seite erklärt die
bundesaußenministerin Anna Lena Berber
man dürfe sich nie wieder abhängig
machen von einem Land das unsere Welt
Werte nicht teilt auf der andere Seite
versuchen Sie russisches Gas zu ersetzen
durch Deals mit den Diktatoren am Golf
oder sagen sie ist es jetzt soweit dass
sie uns weiß machen wollen das Katha und
Saudi-Arabien unsere Werte teilen
Kollegen
dieser Politik der Doppelmoral auch
hinsichtlich China was wir dringend
brauchen ist eine vernünftige
Realpolitik die auf Diplomatie und
Ausgleich setzt anstatt auf
ideologiebetriebene Blockkonfrontation
im Dienste einer vermeintlich höheren
Moral
und ich möchte auch ihnen noch eins
sagen
hören sie auf Deutschland mit ihrem
Gewebe von systemischer Rivalität in
diese Blockkonfrontation der USA mit
China zu treiben China ist Deutschlands
wichtigster Handelspartner
zentraler Rohstofflieferant und einer
der wichtigsten
innovations- und technologiebetreiber
weltweit eine Entkoppelung von China
hätte für die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
in Deutschland katastrophale Folgen wer
weniger Abhängigkeit fordert muss auch
ehrlich sagen
Abhängigkeit ist die Grundlage unseres
Wohlstandes weniger Abhängigkeit
bedeutet weniger Wohlstand das müssen
sie einfach ehrlich mal sagen und ihr
erster Wirtschaftskrieg ist schon ein
Bumerang den die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
hier in Deutschland teuer bezahlen wir
brauchen wahrlich nicht noch einen
zweiten der Deutschland dann voll ins
ruinieren wird vielen Dank
war das aus der Linksfraktion im
Deutschen Bundestag nächster Redner Nils
Schmied lässt aus dem politischer
Sprecher der SPD-Fraktion
Präsident meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren
wie tief muss man sinken liebe Kollegin
dadelen um bei einer Rede über die
chinesische corona-politik nur eine
Aussage zu treffen die bezogen auf die
corona-politik von China aus ihrem Munde
kam nämlich es zu vergleichen mit den
deutschen restriktiven Maßnahmen als wir
Corona bekämpft haben wie tief muss man
trinken und wir erbärmlich ist es dass
sie über alles andere reden bloß nicht
über die Unterdrückung der
Menschenrechte in China wie erbärmlich
ist das
dass kaum jemand von ihrer Fraktion noch
anwesend war bei ihr rede und dass sie
Applaus von Rechtsaußen bekommen haben
zeigt an auf welche rutschige schiefe
Bahn die Linkspartei in der Außenpolitik
sich inzwischen begeben
und ich hätte mir schon gewünscht dass
angesichts der dystopischen Bilder die
uns aus China seit Jahren erreichen Sie
ein paar Worte des Mitgefühls für die
abertausende Jahr Millionen von Menschen
gefunden hätten die seit Jahren
weggesperrt worden sind wo Säuglinge von
ihren Eltern getrennt werden wo
massenhaft infizierte interniert werden
das ist doch das was uns aus China
erreicht und das hat mit den
restriktiven Maßnahmen die in
demokratischen Gesellschaften im Zuge
der corona-bekämpfung getroffen worden
sind nicht aber überhaupt nichts zu tun
und deshalb verwahre ich mich gegen jede
Vermischung in dieser Debatte
ich will aber auch sagen es gibt
ermutigende Bilder aus China das ist ja
auch der Anlass der Debatte Menschen die
aufstehen und sagen sie lassen sich das
nicht mehr länger bieten und Graf
Lambsdorff hat zu Recht darauf
hingewiesen der Wunsch nach Freiheit
nach persönlicher Entfaltung ist
universell
er ist nicht ein Kulturen gebunden er
darf nicht relativiert werden mit dem
Verweis auf vermeintliche asiatische
Werte chinesische Traditionen
afrikanische Werte oder was auch immer
es ist universell und das sollte uns Mut
machen auch im Falle von China die
Gesellschaft in China wird sich
weiterentwickeln ich sehe nicht erwartet
dass das Regime schon oft Höhen und
Füßen stünde aber die Kraft der Freiheit
wird früher oder später auch in China
sich durchsetzen und sich Bahn brechen
und die Menschen in China werden über
den Weg den sie doch ihr Leben schreiten
wollen individuell entscheiden können
und das wollen wir nach Kräften von
außen befördern und unterstützen denn
wir teilen mit diesen Chinesinnen und
Chinesen diesen Wunsch nach Freiheit
in der Bekämpfung des Coronavirus ist
die systemrivalität zwischen autoritären
und demokratischen Systemen deutlich zu
Tage gedrehten der Streit um die beste
Lösung ist in Demokratie möglich das
Ringen um bessere Lösungen das Auswerten
von nicht so erfolgreichen
Lösungsansätzen das ständige verbessern
der Politik ist bei uns im Streit im
Parlament und außerhalb des Parlamentes
auf der Straße in den Medien möglich
während es in China nicht möglich ist
und deshalb ist China ist Präsident sie
jetzt in dieser Sackgasse aus der nicht
herauskommt und ich habe die Vermutung
das ist schon lange nicht mehr nur um
den richtigen Weg der corona-bekämpfung
geht sondern letzten Endes
erleben wir gerade ein groß ein
gesellschaftliches großexperiment in
China wie lange sich eine Gesellschaft
es sich bieten lässt das ein ganzes Volk
weggesperrt wird denn China Politik der
letzten Jahre zieht ja auch auf eine
allgemeine Abschöpfung von der
Weltgesellschaft und des Austausches mit
anderen Gesellschaft in der Welt und
deshalb ist es auch so verständlich dass
die Chinesinnen und Chinesen sich das
nicht länger bieten lassen wir wissen
aber auch die repressionsmittel sind
groß und stark deshalb können wir nicht
draufsetzen das mit einem Schlag
Demokratie und Freiheit sich durchsetzen
aber wir können drei Sachen aus meiner
Sicht sehr sehr deutlich machen erstens
friedliche Proteste das Recht auf freie
Meinungsäußerung auf der Straße muss
auch in China Geld
zweitens Berichterstattung über solche
Proteste muss möglich sein für
Journalistin aus dem In- und Ausland es
darf nicht sein dass Journalisten
weggesperrt werden festgenommen werden
ja misshandelt werden und drittens bei
aller systemrivalität und allen
Wettbewerb den wir in Wirtschaft und
energiefrei mit China
austragen es gibt auch ein Angebot zur
Kooperation es gibt Impfstoffe
westlicher Provenienz die
selbstverständlich auch der chinesischen
Regierung angeboten werden wir sind
bereit Europa ist bereit Impfstoffe zu
teilen mit Chinesen und Chinesen damit
sie einen besseren Impfschutz erreichen
können auch dieses Angebot steht und das
sollten wir auch deutlich aussprechen an
die Menschen in China die diese Hilfe im
Kampf gegen das Corona-Virus dringend
brauchen könnten herzlichen Dank
war das außenpolitischer Sprecher der
SPD-Fraktion und es geht hier nach wie
vor um die Proteste in China um die
deutsche China-Politik die noch nicht so
ganz in den Vordergrund der Aussprache
gerückt ist der nächste Redner ist
Nicolas cipelius aus der Unionsfraktion
des Mitglied im Ausschuss für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren protestkind viele Formen
still laut einsam oder in Massen der
Kollege kreiert hin hat gerade schon
angesprochen in China ist es derzeit ein
weißes Blatt Papier es sind aber auch
Blumensträuße oder eine Tierrasse die
bei richtiger Aussprache auch eine
gewisse Kritik an der Parteiführung
ausdrücken kann und die Bilder die wir
aus China erhalten
die haben Gründe
langfristige Gründe nämlich die Zero
cobbit-politik welche die kommunistische
Parteien nun seit fast drei Jahren
rigoros durchsetzt und kurzfristige
Gründe in dem Fall der Lockdown in
chinchang infolgedessen 10 Personen zu
Tode gekommen waren zu Tode gekommen
weil sie das Gebäude nicht verlassen
konnten dass sie da eingesperrt waren
meine Damen und Herren auch schon
angesprochen aber genauso wichtig vom
Herrn Kollegen Schmied die Proteste
haben ihren Ursprung in einem ureigenen
Streben des Menschen und zwar in dem
Streben nach Freiheit
was ist aber an diesem Protesten anders
landesweite Proteste zum gleichen Thema
sind in China extrem selten wir müssen
diesbezüglich genauer hinsehen denn hier
demonstriert ein Querschnitt der
Bevölkerung Alt und Jung intellektuelle
Arbeiter Landwirte Studenten
handchinesen und andere Ethnien und
daraus gilt es aus die richtigen
Schlüsse zu ziehen die Proteste zeigen
die Unzufriedenheit der Bürger mit dem
Umgang der Zero Corvette Politik mit der
Pandemie und
die Politik sollte ursprünglich
Überlegenheit des eigenen Systems
gegenüber dem Westen zeigen und die
angeblich anfänglichen Erfolge haben
sich inzwischen aber zerschlagen und wir
sehen auch daran sehr genau
Systeme sind eben keine Antwort auf die
großen Herausforderungen unserer Zeit
hier kommen wir aber der Titel sagte
schon zur deutschen China-Politik und da
kann es nicht ganz ohne Kritik bleiben
bislang zu den
Geschehnissen von China bleiben die
Worte der Außenministerin fehlend
bislang ist sie absolut stumm obwohl wir
wissen dass zum Beispiel laut Artikel 35
der chinesische Verfassung die Rede und
Versammlungsfreiheit geschützt ist und
wir erwarten von unserer Seite dass das
Außenministerium und die Außenministerin
da eine klare Botschaft übersendet
[Applaus]
und so kommen wir auch zu China-Politik
und auf die china-strategie zu sprechen
denn die China-Politik der
Bundesregierung die steht für das
Handeln der Ampelkoalition in
vergangenen Jahr sinnbildlich entgegen
der ersten Ankündigung hängt sie dem
Zeitplan hinterher sie bleibt weit
hinter den Erwartungen zurück und eine
Einigkeit ist überhaupt nicht
ersichtlich viel schlimmer noch der
Streit bezüglich der China Strategie und
der China Politik wird in der Koalition
ganz offen auf offener Bühne ausgetragen
und man fragt sich dann schon wenn die
Außenministerin einerseits einen Werte
geleiteten Ansatz propagiert
wo der enden soll denn dieser Wert werde
geleitet der Ansatz der bröckelt oder
bröckelt nicht auf internationaler Bühne
nein der zerbröckelt am Widerstand 400
Meter von hier entfernt im Bundeskanzler
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
und wir beschäftigen uns als
Unionsfraktion intensiv mit der China
Politik der Bundesregierung aus meinem
Büro stammen mehrere schriftliche
Anfragen wir haben eine kleine Anfrage
zur china-strategie der Bundesregierung
gestellt mit 57 konkreten Fragen 57
konkrete Fragen unter anderem z.B zu den
Leitlinien der Bundesregierung der Inno
pazifikstrategie aus dem Jahr 2021 und
wie die konkreten die China Strategie
eingearbeitet wird ein Drittel ein
Drittel dieser Frage wurde mit einer
standardisierten Antwort beantwortet und
wenn zeitgleich dich hier im
Regierungsviertel Journalisten über den
ersten Wurf der China Strategie verfügen
dann kann man an dieser Stelle nur sagen
die nicht Beantwortung unserer Kleinen
Anfrage während gleichzeitig aus dem
Außenministerium an Journalisten
durchgesteckt wird das ist eine Form der
Missachtung des Parlaments was überhaupt
nicht geht meine Damen und Herren
das stimmt und
apropos Entwurf China Strategie der
Bundesregierung in diesem kommt das Wort
Diaspora zum Beispiel kein einziges Mal
vor wenn wir allerdings wissen welche
Bedeutung Auslands Chinesen für die
chinesische Führung haben ist dieser
blinde Fleck in der Ausarbeitung des
Außenministeriums gerade zu fatal und
das zieht sich durch das zieht sich
durch die Außenministerin will nach
außen Härte projizieren und gleichzeitig
trifft sich der Bundeskanzler unter vier
Augen in China springen und spricht
danach von Verlässlichkeit und Vertrauen
und da Liebe Koalition China Politik
müssen sie sich immer wieder darüber
planen werden was das auch für ein
Zeichen nach außen gibt der renommierte
französische China-Experte
Francois weil das Statement des
Bundeskanzlers zu Verlässlichkeit und
Vertrauen pures Entsetzen und ich komme
zum Schluss wir müssen an dieser Stelle
bemerken
die Kompetenz bezüglich der Außenpolitik
die liegt bei mit Sicherheit nicht im
Außenministerium die liegt bei
Bundeskanzler Scholz und bei seinem
wichtigsten beraten Herrn blödner von
dem es heißt dass er die Außenpolitik
deutlicher gestalten wird als die
außenministerinisterin in dieser
Legislatur jemals können wird herzlichen
Dank
Nicolas sipelius war das und ich kann
nur sagen kaum habe ich es reklamiert
gehabt dass hier die China Strategie der
Bundesregierung noch nicht im
Mittelpunkt steht wird sie im Mittel
oder steht sie im Mittelpunkt der
Redebeitrags von Nicolas cipelius und
wir können mal ein bisschen mutmaßen das
ist eine direkte Erwiderung zu dem einen
und anderen Punkt jetzt geben wird von
Tobias Lindner der ist Staatsminister
bei der Bundesministerin des auswärtigen
liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
der tragische Tod von zehn Menschen bei
einem Wohnhausbrand in der
nordwestchinesischen Stadt rumschied
mutmaßlich starben weil zur besseren
kobit-kontrolle wichtige Notausgänge
verflossen waren hat eine Welle von
Protestkundgebungen in China ausgelöst
die Unzufriedenheit mit einem Politik
der chinesischen Führung ist so groß
dass viele Menschen bereit sind enorm
Risiken auf sich zu nehmen um ihre
Meinung öffentlich zu äußern das zeigen
die friedlichen Proteste in Peking in
Shanghai in Wuhan und in vielen anderen
chinesischen Städten seit dem
vergangenen Wochenende die Menschen in
China darunter viele junge Frauen machen
mit ihren Protesten von ihrem
Menschenrecht auf freie
Meinungsäußerungen Gebrauch einem recht
dass wir in freien Gesellschaft und
wieder unsringen oft als
selbstverständlich erachten und zudem
sich China in seiner Verfassung es ist
bereits erwähnt worden ebenfalls
verpflichtet hat die Ereignisse
dass sie immer willkürlich aber
Durchsetzung der sogenannten Null
kobe-politik nicht mehr von der
Bevölkerung akzeptiert wird und sie
zeigen auch meine Damen und Herren das
ist den Menschen in China eben nicht
egal ist was in shingyang passiert die
Solidarisierung zwischen Chinesinnen und
Chinesen und in den Yang unterdrückten
olguren hat sich damit zum ersten Mal
innerhalb Chinas öffentlich und für
jeden sichtbar manifestiert liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ganz besonders
sticht mir dabei ins Auge dass die
Forderungen nach Lockerung der Politik
vielfach auch mit Forderungen nach
politischen Wandel verbunden werden wir
sehen einmal mehr dass es eben nicht
möglich ist in einer Gesellschaft jeder
abweichende Meinung dauerhaft zu
unterdrücken und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen da Mut derjenigen Menschen in
China die es wagen sich der
allgegenwärtigen Überwachung
Unterdrückung und
einschüchterungsversuchende staatliche
Stellen offen entgegen zu dieser Mut
liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen verdient
unseren Respekt und unsere Hochachtung
die leider zu erwarten war hat die
chinesische Führung mit repressiven
Maßnahmen mit noch weiniger Ausweitung
der Internetzensur und mit massiver
Einschüchterung der Bevölkerung auf
diese Proteste reagiert wir appellieren
daher an die chinesische Regierung den
Wunsch und das Recht der eigenen
Regierung nach freier Meinungsäußerung
zu achten und sich mit ihren
berechtigten Anliegen
auseinanderzusetzen wir appellieren
ferner an die chinesische Regierung mehr
zu tun um die Freiheit der Presse zu
schützen die kurzzeitige Inhaftierung
und Misshandlung eines Journalisten der
BBC im Zusammenhang mit seiner
berichtsausstattung zu den Protesten in
Shanghai sendet ein
besorgniserregendes Zeichen in alle Welt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen natürlich
hoffen wir dass die chinesische
Regierung auf die Anliegen der
Protestierenden eingehen wird wir sehen
erste Zeichen für gewisse sehr
vorsichtige Schritte in eine richtige
Richtung bei der Anwendung der Politik
so wurden beispielsweise bestehende
Bezirksleiter lockdowns in Kanton
aufgehoben es soll dort keine weiteren
Massentests mehr geben aber lassen Sie
mich klar betonen es bleibt abzuwarten
ob dies von Dauer sein wird die
chinesische Regierung steht angesichts
neuer Varianten die anstecken das sind
als sie bisherigen und stark zunehmender
Fallzahlen vor einem Dilemma es fällt
ihr immer schwerer ihre
gesundheitspolitischen Maßnahmen und die
Belange ihrer Bevölkerung und der
Wirtschaft in einen vernünftigen
Ausgleich zu bringen
und in diesem Kontext hat unter von
Bundeskanzler Scholz gemacht das Angebot
Zusammenarbeit bei mrna-impfungen in
China eine herausragende Bedeutung die
Bundesregierung bekennt sich zu diesem
Angebot und wir hoffen dass China
zuzügig auf unsere Vorschläge auch
eingehen wird meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren
bereits angesprochen worden sie wissen
die Bundesregierung arbeitet und hat auf
Federführung des Auswärtigen Amtes
derzeit an einer umfassenden Strategie
zum zukünftigen Umgang mit China wir
wollen eine enger koordinierte mehr an
unseren und europäischen Werten und
Interessen
ausgerichtete China-Politik diese Werte
und Interessen wollen wir effektiver als
bisher verteidigen und wir müssen daher
unsere einzeitigen Abhängigkeiten von
China reduzieren und somit auch weniger
verwundbar werden deswegen wollen wir
konkret unsere
außenwirtschaftsförderungsinstrumente
auch als Anreiz für Firmen einsetzen um
dort Diversifikation voranzutreiben wir
schauen auch sehr genau hin bei
ausländischen Investitionen hier in
Deutschland lassen sie mit es mich klar
sagen Deutschland ist eine offene
Marktwirtschaft die Investition wünscht
und fördert
aber diese dürfen nicht unsere
öffentliche Ordnung und Sicherheit
gefährden und wir haben von dem
Hintergrund des russischen
angriffskriegs aus der Ukraine bitter
lernen müssen welche Folgen einseitige
Abhängigkeiten für unsere
Volkswirtschaft haben können meine Damen
und Herren wir werden unsere Lehren
daraus ziehen und wir werden diesen
Fehler kein zweites Mal mehr begehen
und gleichzeitig wollen wir uns nicht
von China entkoppeln und Dialog und
Zusammenarbeit möglich sind wollen wir
diese fortsetzen sei es in Politik und
Wirtschaft das heißt in Wissenschaft und
Kultur die Europäische Union definiert
ihre Beziehungen zu China in allen
Dreiklang Partner
Konkurrent
systemischer Rivale und wir müssen
leider feststellen dass dieses chemische
Rivalität aktuell immer mehr Raum
einnimmt dass sie zu dominierenden
Faktor wird und von diesem Hintergrund
müssen wir dort wo Partnerschaft richtig
und wichtig ist dann Partnerschaft auch
entsprechend denken wir sehen aktuell
das ist kein monolithisches China gibt
wie es uns chinesische Staatsmedien
glauben machen wollen wir tun deshalb in
unserer Strategie gut daran auch
weiterhin den Austausch mit chinesischen
Partnerinnen und Partnern versuchen
und lassen Sie mich betonen wir müssen
uns mit dem China auseinandersetzen wie
wir es tatsächlich vorfinden nicht wie
wir es uns wünschen oder wie wäre es
gerne hätten und um den Bundeskanzler zu
zitieren in China sich ändert dann muss
ich auch unser Umgang mit China ändern
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
klar ist wir wollen trotz aller
Differenzen auch dort wo wir China
brauchen in Zukunft zusammenarbeiten
dabei geht es nicht nur um
wirtschaftliche Fragen dabei geht es im
globale fragen wie die Klimakrise wie
Fragen von Frieden und Sicherheit wie
dem Schutz von natürlichen
Lebensgrundlagen der
Nahrungsmittelsicherheit oder globalen
Gesundheitsfragen diese
Herausforderungen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen werden wir nicht ohne das
bevölkerungsreichste Land der Erde als
verantwortungsvollen Partner bewältigen
können und hier möchte ich auch noch
einmal
das Ergebnis der Kopf 27 in Erinnerung
rufen es ist uns dort gelungen eine
Einigung zum schweren Thema los und
damage zu erreichen eine Einigung die
auch und gerade China als sie mit
Abstand größten Emittenten von CO2
verpflichtet für die Bewältigung von
Klimaschäden aufzukommen diese Treffen
oft die Ärmsten und damit
verletzlichsten Länder am stärksten
deshalb ist es wichtig dass die größten
Verursacher auch in der Verantwortung
stehen die Folgen zu bekämpfen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Zusammenarbeit mit China somit weiter
wichtig aber lassen Sie mich in aller
Deutlichkeit sagen
wir wollen eine Zusammenarbeit nach den
Spielregeln und den Grundsätzen der
internationalen
regelbasierten Ordnung im Einklang mit
unseren Interessen und unseren Werten
und es entspricht unseren Werten das
Kritik an der Regierung und das Recht
auf freie Meinungsäußerung möglich sein
müssen
und deshalb stehen wir heute deshalb
stehen wir heute solidarisch an der
Seite aller Menschen die ihre
elementaren Grundrechte auch und gerade
auf freie Meinungsäußerung wahrnehmen
wollen in China und weltweit ich danke
Ihnen
wir werden unsere Lehren ziehen was
Abhängigkeit von anderen Staaten angeht
wir wollen uns aber auch von China nicht
komplett entkoppeln sagt Tobias Lindner
Staatsminister bei der Bundesministerin
des auswärtigen in dieser Debatte über
die Lage in China aber auch über die
deutsche China Politik dazu jetzt
güdingensen stellvertretende Vorsitzende
der FDP-Fraktion
herzlichen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen alle Menschen
sind frei und gleich an Würde und
Rechten geboren das ist der erste Satz
des ersten Artikels der Allgemeinen
Erklärung der Menschenrechte und jedes
Wort dieses Satzes ist elementar aber
steckt ein ganz besonderes Wort da drin
das besonders Autokraten in der Welt
riesige Angst macht
alle Menschen sind frei geboren egal ob
Russinnen Russen US-Amerikanerinnen
belarussinnen Iranerin oder eben
Chinesen alle Menschen tragen diesen
Wunsch nach Freiheit nach
Selbstbestimmung in sich es gibt keine
chinesischen Menschenrechte Chinesen
wollen nicht weniger frei oder weniger
selbstbestimmt sein es ist die
kommunistische Partei China die will
dass die Menschen in China unfrei und
weniger selbstbestimmt leben
auf der ganzen Welt nutzen Autokraten
gewissermaßen wie die Kommunistische
Partei Chinas gerade beobachten ein ganz
bestimmtes narrativ um ihr
unterdrückerisches Regime immer wieder
zurechtfertigen unsere Kultur ist eine
andere sagen sie Menschenrechte sein ein
westliches Konstrukt diese Proteste
übrigens genau wie die Proteste auch in
Iran die entlarven aber diese Erzählung
mehr denn je als große als mutwillige
als menschenverachtende Lüge meine Damen
und Herren Menschenrechte sind kein
westliches Konstrukt Menschenrechte sind
ein menschliches Konstrukt
die Kommunistische Partei Chinas hat die
chinesische Zivilgesellschaft
systematisch zerstört aber die
bürgerliche Haltung in jedem einzelnen
Chinesen in jeder einzelnen Chinesin an
die kommt die Kommunistische Partei
nicht heran auch wenn das mit einem
immer größer werdenden totalitären
überwachungsstark Staat immer weiter
versucht wird liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das was wir in den letzten
Tagen in China sehen das sind aus meiner
Wahrnehmung nicht unbedingt nur die
Proteste gegen die drakonische zero-
[Musik]
sie rufen nieder mit der Kommunistischen
Partei sie fordern Transparenz sie
riskieren dafür ihre Freiheit denn in
China erfasst jede Kamera dein Gesicht
wenn du protestieren gehst und
anschließend ruft die Kommunistische
Partei bei dir zu Hause an und droht dir
deiner Familie deinen Freunden ganz
unverhohlen mit Konsequenzen und wenn du
nicht verprügelt wirst oder ins
Gefängnis gesteckt wirst dann kommst Du
vielleicht keine eigene Wohnung dann
verlierst du den Anspruch auf deinen Job
auf Kinderbetreuung weil das Social
creditsystem weil das System es so will
wie groß liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wie groß muss eigentlich die Überzeugung
sein wie groß muss der Druck sein um in
einem Land wie China zu demonstrieren
denn den Menschen in diesem Land ist es
ernst liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und
wenn wir jetzt nicht mehr so viel
darüber hören wie noch am Wochenende
über die Proteste dann liegt es vor
allen Dingen auch daran dass der
Überwachungsapparat dass der
zensur-apparat noch stärker ans Laufen
gekommen ist und wirkt und deshalb ist
besonders auch internationaler
Journalismus deshalb ist die Debatte die
wir auch hier führen die Öffentlichkeit
die Aufmerksamkeit für dieses Thema
elementar und deshalb haben wir als
Koalition genau auch diese aktuelle
Stunde hier heute auf die Tagesordnung
gesetzt erwartet nicht zuletzt um ein
Zeichen an China zu senden dass wir für
euch sehen dass wir wissen dass es Euch
ernst ist und dass diese Proteste nicht
klein bleiben werden
das weiß im übrigen auch die
Kommunistische Partei deshalb fährt sie
ja alles auf was der
Unterdrückungsapparat zu bieten hat und
wir müssen uns hier darüber verständigen
was wir mit weiteren Eskalationen tun
wie gehen wir damit um genau dafür
brauchen wir einen Plan und auch in
diesem an diesem Punkt
ja an diesem Punkt holen uns Herr Wade
vor Sie haben ja schon ein bisschen
darauf in ihrer Rede rekoriert da holen
uns die Versäumnisse der letzten
Bundesregierung
nee das sage ich nicht Herr März wir
haben hier wir haben hier vor zwei
Jahren gestanden da saßen sie noch in
der Mitte da wo wir jetzt Gott sei Dank
sitzen und da hat der Kollege Wade holen
und andere Kolleginnen und Kollegen als
wir genau diesen Punkt gemacht haben es
war gerade das nationale
Sicherheitsgesetz in Hongkong
verabschiedet worden
da haben sie hier gesessen als wir
gesagt haben wir müssten den EU
china-gipfel absagen weil wir zu diesem
Zeitpunkt auf dieser Grundlage nicht
einfach weitermachen können wie vorher
da lagen sie fast unterm Tisch vor
Lachen und vor Verächtlichkeit dieser
Forderungen gegenüber und wir holen
jetzt das nach was sie die letzten Jahre
versäumt haben und es wäre wichtig
gewesen dieses Problembewusstsein zu
erkennen es wäre wichtig gewesen eine
aktive Analyse der Abhängigkeiten der
notwendigen Resilienz zu schaffen
stattdessen haben sie das nicht gemacht
wir werden eine Ressort übergreifende
china-strategie vorlegen und wir werden
dafür sorgen dass die die die Fehler die
im Grunde bei diesem nicht akzeptieren
der Realität kommt frau Kollegin ich
komme zum Schluss nicht mehr gemacht
werden
der Freiheitsdrang eines jeden
Individuums der ist stärker als jede
Ideologie
erhalten unglaublich wichtig für die
Menschen die sie nicht freihalten können
herzlichen Dank
Güdingen stellvertretende Vorsitzende
der FDP-Fraktion sieht diese Debatte
hier die aktuelle Stunde im Bundestag
zur Lage in China zur deutschen China
Politik auch als ein Zeichen an China
und die Protestierenden dort und sie
vermisst so hat sie gerade noch gesagt
das Problem Bewusstsein innerhalb der
Union zumindest hat sich vermisst was
die vergangene Legislaturperiode angeht
Alexander Rad waren ist am poold aus der
Unionsfraktion Mitglied der CSU
Landesgruppe
und die nehmen zu ja lassen wir mal
einen Teil weg
aber unabhängig davon sollten wir auch
wissen dass die Thematik wie wir sie
hier vortragen natürlich mehr oder
weniger zu Propaganda Zwecken dort
genutzt werden dass das alles vom
Ausland gesteuert wird und darum
konzentriere ich mich jetzt auf den
zweiten Teil dieser aktuellen Stunde die
Kinderpolitik
und wir erleben momentan ja
dynamische Entwicklungen in China bei
dem Protestierenden
und es kann auch außenpolitische Dynamik
geben wir wissen wie Ping sich geäußert
hat wie er sich selber positioniert hat
in seinem reden und darum müssen wir in
unserer Kinderpolitik das Undenkbare
denken eine Dynamik kann jederzeit
auftreten und darum teile ich es dass
diversifizieren wichtig ist und die wir
infizieren heißt gleichzeitig keinen
Bruch vornehmen
ansonsten können wir die Energie und
mobilitätswende von einem Tag auf den
anderen Tag einstampfen
Risiko reduzieren heißt Alternativen
schaffen
wenn wir jetzt Glück haben werden wir im
glaube ich 12ten Anlauf diese Woche
zieht er vereinbaren können ratifizieren
können meine Damen und Herren
was verstehen wir denn unter
diversifizieren dass wir neue Partner
finden was heißt es denn konkret mit
mehr Kultur meine Damen und Herren das
nächste müsste das Merkur so Abkommen
sein dass wir dieses entsprechend
vorantreiben ratifizieren und heute und
heute recht es sich dass manchen in der
Ampel das chlorhühnchen wichtiger war
als eine Vereinbarung mit den USA der im
fleischischen reduction act in der
jetzigen Phase ist ein Riesenproblem für
unsere Wirtschaft meine Damen und Herren
Reziprozität sollte man nicht nur im
Mund führen meine Damen und Herren China
kann in dem Hafen in Hamburg investieren
umgekehrt ist es nicht möglich die
Rechte der chinesischen Unternehmen hier
ist stärker geschützt als die der
deutschen Unternehmen in China da ist
dringender Handlungsbedarf meine Damen
und Herren
und meine Damen und Herren
Alternativen heißt andere Partner in der
Welt finden
es hat ja der Kollege wadeful angedeutet
oder beide Kollegen haben es angedeutet
dass die bisherige china-strategie über
die Medien kommuniziert wurde da stand
an erster Stelle Menschenrechte und
Klima es versuche ich das
zusammenzukriegen gestern haben wir
einen Vereinbarung mit entsprechenden
Katar bekommen und ihr
Bundeswirtschaftsminister hat es
gefeiert und hat sogar gesagt es ist zu
kurz ich stimme im ausdrücklich zu aber
wie kriegen sie es dann mit der Kritik
der Außenministerin in Sharm el Sheikh
bei Kopf 27 zu den Golfstaaten zusammen
genau das Gegenteil ist richtiges
Handeln hier das Wirtschaftsministers
unterstützt aber sie in seiner Fraktion
boykottierendes
nächsten diesen dezember findet eine
Konferenz in Riad statt der Golfstaaten
mit China Saudi Arabien mit
china-arabischen Welt mit China meine
Damen und Herren dort werden diese
Staaten ihre interessenvertreten ich
wäre dankbar Herr Staatsminister wenn es
ein Stück weit ein in die deutsche
Außenpolitik hinein käme dass wir unsere
Interessen in der Welt vertreten müssen
und nicht nur missionarisch unterwegs
sind
die beste Kinderpolitik meine Damen und
Herren und es hat keiner angesprochen
auch sie hat Kritik nicht ist ein
starkes Deutschland in der Welt das
bedeutet es wirtschaftlich das bedeutet
das innovativ und das bedeutet es
militärisch das was bisher hier passiert
ist auf der durch die Bundesregierung
lässt der zum wünschen übrig es wurde
mehrfach die Pharmaindustrie
angesprochen die Rückverlagerung der
Pharmaproduktion aus China nach Europa
ich wäre froh meine Damen und Herren
wenn es nicht nur
das was bisher abgewandert ist sondern
wenn wir in Deutschland darauf setzen
würde innovative Technologie
zurückzuholen oder hier entsprechend zu
fördern ich sage Stichwort Gentechnik
ich habe einen Bericht bekommen dass ein
Bundesminister der Grünen ein Medikament
das in den USA gerade zugelassen wird
auf gentechnischer Basis zur Heilung von
Parkinson erklärt hat ja dann wollen wir
ein solches Medikament nicht in Europa
meine Damen und Herren das ist der
falsche Ansatz für eine gute
Außenpolitik eine starke Außenpolitik in
Deutschland und meine Damen und Herren
allerdings muss ich Ihnen sagen in der
jetzigen Phase weiß ich nicht ob das
größte Problem der deutschen Wirtschaft
die Energiekrise ist oder der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister bei dem
Bundeswirtschaftsminister habe ich
momentan meine größten bedenkung ob der
überhaupt in der Lage ist uns in dieser
Phase entsprechend zu steuern besten
Dank
und für die SPD Alex und Alexander
Rathmann war der drittletzte Redner in
dieser aktuellen Stunde zum Thema China
und China Politik Frank Schwabe folglich
der vorletzte Sprecher für
Menschenrechte und humanitäre Hilfe in
der SPD-Fraktion dann sind verehrte
Damen und Herren in der Tat wir leben in
einer Welt das ist glaube ich auch
deutlich gewordene Debatte die sich neu
sortiert und bei allem schrecklichen was
wir gerade in der Welt erleben gibt es
aber eben auf Hoch auf Hoffnungsschimmer
mit dem man vielleicht gar nicht
gerechnet hat und ich finde diese
Proteste in China gehören entsprechend
dazu wir haben ja nicht nur den Eindruck
in den letzten Jahren gehabt dass ich
die Lage verschlechtert für
Menschenrechte Demokratie und Freiheit
in vielen Ländern der Welt sondern es
geht mir auch die Daten entsprechend her
aber wir haben eben diese Entwicklung
jetzt in China wir haben sie im Iran wir
hatten sie auch und haben Sie vielleicht
noch in Belarus in nordafrikanischen
Staaten Staaten und wir haben sie und
hoffentlich haben wir Sie demnächst noch
mehr in Russland das heißt es gibt
diesen Willen zur Freiheit es gibt
diesen Willen
zu Menschenrechten und es ist eben
nichts was vom Westen gesteuert ist
sondern es kommt von den Menschen selbst
es kommt aus den Gesellschaften und es
verdient unsere volle Sympathie Respekt
und unsere volle Unterstützung
und es ist eben und es ist auch in der
Debatte deutlich geworden es sind nicht
nur die corona-maßnahmen sondern es
kulminiert im Grunde genommen bei den
corona-maßnahmen es ist eine
Allmachtsfantasie ein totalitärer Staat
in China der glaubt alles am Ende regeln
zu können und mit den Menschen machen zu
können was sie wollen und es ist schon
wirklich in Form und böswillig das zu
vergleichen mit corona-maßnahmen in
einem demokratischen Staat wo man alles
behaupten kann und alles entsprechend
diskutieren kann
es gibt diese Repressalien diese
Unterdrückung der Menschen im Inland und
es gibt eben damit gepaart und das
erleben wir nicht nur bei China sondern
bei vielen anderen Ländern auf der Welt
auch auch eine Aggressivität nach außen
das war lange bei China anders aber das
ist mittlerweile leider eben auch so und
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir die
China-Politik gemeinsam neu justieren
das ist eine china-strategie gibt und ob
da was durchgestochen wird oder nicht am
Ende sein sie mal sicher wird eine
gemeinsame china-strategie dieser
Bundesregierung geben und ich glaube das
ist auch in der Debatte heute deutlich
geworden
wir haben parallel und die
menschenrechtspolitikerinnen und
Politiker sind ein bisschen mussten hier
rüberkommen einige von uns wir haben
parallel eine Anhörung drüben ein paar
ein paar Meter weiter und diese Anhörung
ist zum Thema systemischer Wettbewerb
Menschenrechte als integraler
Bestandteil der Weltordnung und ich will
zitieren ganz frisch Professor Heiner
Bielefeld der das sehr überzeugend noch
mal deutlich gemacht hat der gesagt hat
die Attraktivität der Menschenrechtsidee
ist ungebrochen und im Moment
symbolisieren weiße Blätter in China
diese ungebrochene Attraktivität der
Menschenrechte
China verletzt Menschenrechte wirklich
in epochaler und multiple Art und Weise
und auch das ist gerade schon gesagt
worden das ist falsch es ist falsch
Entwicklungspolitik an Entwicklung eines
Landes gegen Menschenrechte in Stellung
zu bringen es ist falsch Werte als
westliche Werte zu diffamieren weil
diejenigen die dort auf der Straße
stehen diejenigen Chinesen und Chinesen
die dort protestieren die meinen genau
die Menschenrechte die universellen
Menschenrechte die wir hier entsprechend
jedenfalls die meisten von uns auch
meinen wenn man über China redeten
Menschenrechtsverletzungen dann
kulminiert dann könnte man bei viele
Beispiele reden über Hongkong Tibet und
vieles andere aber als kulminiert in der
Tat injean und deswegen ist es schon ja
fast symbolisch das ist am Ende zehn
Tote in nur rumschiebern die bei einem
Feuer ums Leben gekommen sind die am
Ende jetzt diese Proteste ausgelöst
haben in den djang wo wir wirklich
Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit
erleben in einer Art und Weise wie man
sich das in einem einer modernen Welt
eigentlich nicht vorstellen kann wo wir
Massen Inhaftierungen sehen von bis zu
einer Million Menschen wo wir Folter
sehen und die kulturelle Verfolgung von
Uiguren und anderen turkstämmigen
Muslimen wichtig ist im Umgang mit China
und das ist wahrscheinlich bei allen
Schwierigkeiten die wir sonst noch so
haben der schwierigste Partner in der
Welt wichtig ist dass wir in der Tat ein
unverstellten und einen klaren Blick auf
die Lage haben dass wir eine klare
Unterstützung geben und das sollten wir
jedenfalls in der Breite des Hauses
geben für die freiheitsliebenden in
China dass wir keinen Handel abbrechen
wollen aber wir wollen in der Tat
diversifizieren und wir wollen dass
menschenrechtliche Regeln zum Beispiel
im Rahmen von lieferkettengesetzen
angewendet werden in den
Handelsbeziehungen mit China und wir
brauchen und ich glaube das ist die
Lehre dieser Proteste einen
selbstbewussten Umgang mit universellen
Menschenrechten das war eine Schande das
China sich durchgesetzt hat im
unmenschenrechtsrat um eben nicht über
den Jang am Ende reden zu müssen aber
gleichzeitig haben wir gesehen dass es
beim Iran mit deutlicher Mehrheit
gelungen ist dort tätig zu werden wir
haben gesehen dass die
Generalversammlung zu Russland eine
klare Mehrheit hat und ich glaube das
macht Hoffnung auf eine Welt wo
Menschenrechte Freiheit und Demokratie
eine Rolle spielen und wichtig sind und
es gibt sie eben diese Menschen die sich
nach Freiheit und Menschenrechten sehen
und in China sehen wir sie jetzt eben
auch und das verdient unseren vollen
Respekt und unsere volle Unterstützung
Frank Schwabe für die SPD-Fraktion in
der Aktuellen Stunde zum Thema China mit
die eröffnet wurde von Jürgen Trittin im
außenpolitischen Sprecher der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und eine der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzende der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen schließt
diese Debatte jetzt auch an jeschka
Brugger ist die letzte Rednerin
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen als Zeichen des Protests genügt
in China heute mittlerweile ein weißes
Blatt Papier mehr gibt es nicht zu sagen
so bringen es die Protestierenden dort
auf den Punkt und wir erleben dieser
Tage eine sehr mutigende
beeindruckende Bewegung inzwischen in
zahlreichen Großstädten die größte seit
den Prozessen 1989 im Land die im
Tierheim Massaker blutig
niedergeschlagen wurden wie 1989 oder
auch bei der Demokratiebewegung in
Hongkong bei den krassen Menschen
verrechtsverletzungen an den Uiguren in
Tibet ja und auch von dieser Debatte
sollte die Botschaft an die Menschen
dort ausgehen wir haben euch nicht
vergessen
die bei all diesen Entwicklungen kennt
die chinesische Regierung auch bei den
aktuellen Protesten wieder nur eine
Antwort Menschenrechtsverletzungen
massive Polizeipräsenz Festnahme und
Einschüchterungen Zensur und
Unterdrückung
die chinesische Bevölkerung sie leidet
unter einer gescheiterten impfstrategie
unter der Blockade von modernen mRNA
Impfstoffen und die großflächigen und
teilweise wochenlangen harten lockdowns
helfen eben nicht gegen Omicron sie
führen viel mehr zur gesundheitlicher
und sozialer Not mit extremen
ökonomischen und sozialen Folgeschäden
Produktionsausfällen gestörten
Lieferketten die dann auch wiederum zu
niedrigsten Wachstumsrate seit Jahren
führen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
tragische Brand ich komme gleich zu
ihnen mit zehn Todesopfer bei dem die
Löscharbeiten durch den regidenden
Lockdown erschwert worden sind das war
der konkrete Auslöser der Proteste es
geht aber den Protestierenden eben nicht
allein nur um eine harte
unverhältnismäßige lockdown-politik die
BürgerInnen in China haben gespürt das
unter dem Vorwand der pandemiebekämpfung
die chinesische Führung ihre
Möglichkeiten zur Kontrolle bis in den
privatesten Bereich noch weiter
ausgebaut hat
und es muss endlich auch aufhören dass
immer wieder westliche Konzerne der
chinesischen Führung die Möglichkeit
lassen oder sie ihr gar geben ihren
umfassenden Überwachungsapparat immer
weiter auszubauen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist
die Unzufriedenheit über die
wirtschaftlichen Probleme die
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit über die
Immobilien und Bankenkrise es ist der
Wunsch nach Freiheit noch Offenheit den
die Menschen aus ihren Herzen und Köpfen
auf die Straße
tragen und diese Sehnsucht die verstehen
wir die sehen wir und die unterstützen
wir
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es sind
gerade die Rechtsextremen politischen
Kräfte die hier sonst so gerne die
Autokraten hofieren und verehren und
zugleich sehr erfolglos übrigens
versuchen eine Werte geleitete und
menschenrechtsorientierte Politik ins
Lächerliche zu ziehen wenn Sie nun den
Mut und die Motivation der Menschen in
China missbrauchen damit es in ihre
Pandemie verschwörungsmieten Propaganda
passt dann ist das nicht nur zutiefst
zynisch und dumm sondern das ist eine
Entnahme Instrumentalisierung dieser
mutigen Menschen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn ich
auch an die Debatten aus der Anfangszeit
der Pandemie denke und all die
Besserwisser die vorhersagten das
autokratische Regime in der Pandemie
doch handlungsfähiger sein dann kann man
nur sagen sie haben sich getäuscht nicht
erst die aktuellen Proteste in China
machen deutlich Regime die ihren Bürger
in den Menschenrechte und freiheite
verwehren sind nur vermeintlich stabil
Autokratien sind eben nicht besser
geeignet um Lösungen zu finden sie leben
in einer permanenten Angst vor der
eigenen Bevölkerung und die Repression
und Unterdrückung sie sind Ausdruck von
Angst sie sind kein Zeichen der Stärke
wie viele Autokratien handelt China aber
nicht nur zunehmend in politisch äußerst
repressiv auch in der Außenpolitik kennt
die Kommunistische Partei vor allem eine
Richtung die militärischen Drohungen
gegenüber den Menschen in Taiwan werden
immer aggressiver die Lage im
Südchinesischen Meer wird schwieriger
und gefährlicher wir haben es in den
letzten Jahren einmal mehr als deutlich
erlebt ob bei der Klimakrise der
Pandemie den zahlreichen Kriegen es
betrifft auch unsere Gesellschaft unsere
Wirtschaft und unseren Alltag wenn die
regelbasierte internationale Ordnung und
ihre grundlegenden Werte verletzt werden
und auch deshalb dürfen uns die
steigenden Sorgen der Menschen in Taiwan
nicht egal sein
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen unsere
außenpolitische Antwort auf die
komplizierte Situation im Indopazifik
sie sollte aber nicht eine des
Gegeneinanders sein sondern eine des
Miteinanders und der Zusammenarbeit und
deshalb wollen wir diese auch Stärke mit
Staaten wie Japan wie Australien wir
Neuseeland und den vielen Partnerinnen
und Partnern in Südostasien auch das
wird die china-strategie der
Bundesregierung die Annalena baerburg
gerade erstellt beschreiben genau kommen
Sie bitte zum Schluss mit einem weiter
so der Vergangenheit sie wird die
Grundlage bilden für eine China-Politik
die Werte und Interessen nicht
gegeneinander ausspielt sondern in der
sie Hand in Hand zusammenlaufen vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
war das hier zur deutschen China-Politik
in der Aktuellen Stunde das Thema wird
uns natürlich noch länger beschäftigen
denn wir hier auch angeklungen ist wird
sich die Bundesregierung natürlich damit
auseinandersetzen müssen wie Deutschland
sich China gegenüber verhält wir bleiben
international und gehen gleichzeitig
aber auf Deutschland es geht um das un
Übereinkommen zur Frauen Diskriminierung
bzw wir haben hier eine 5-minütige
Unterbrechung weil laut Tagesordnung
eben der nächste Tagesordnungspunkt erst
später stattfindet das ist auch für uns
eine kleine Überraschung das war etwas
anders
angekündigt aber wir können ja die Zeit
nutzen
um schon mal auf das nächste Thema
schauen was jetzt
was jetzt demnächst kommen wird das ist
nämlich der Bericht zum un ein
Übereinkommen zur Frauen Diskriminierung
das Übereinkommen heißt
ausgesprochen Konvention on the
elimination of all forms of
discrimination against women und das
bedeutet eben die Beseitigung jeder Form
von Diskriminierung der Frau was
bedeutet das es geht um die nationale
Frauenförderung aber zum Beispiel auch
um Themen wie die geschlechtsspezifische
Gewalt gegen Frauen die Menschen handelt
die Ausbeutung in der Prostitution aber
z.B auch um Teilhabe am politischen und
öffentlichen Leben es geht um Bildung
Beschäftigung und Gesundheit und eben
wie besonders benachteiligte Gruppen
geschützt werden können geflüchtete und
Asylsuchende Frauen sind zum Beispiel
deutlich die anderen Gefahren ausgesetzt
als Männer das wird immer wieder klar
und wir werden gleich im Meer dazu
erfahren wie Deutschland diese
das umsetzt dass Sie sich dafür einsetzt
eben diese un Übereinkommen umzusetzen
die Zeit jetzt wollen wir aber nutzen um
ihn noch
nachzuliefern was der
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck heute
gesagt hat und das zeigen Ihnen die
Kollegen aus Bonn
ja vielen Dank Katharina kühn nach
Berlin in den Deutschen Bundestag
so liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
unterbrochene Sitzung ist wieder
eröffnet
und ich rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt
3 sowie den Zusatzpunkt
2 die Beratung der Unterrichtung über
den neuen Bericht der Bundespolitik
Deutschland der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland zum Übereinkommen der
Vereinten Nationen zu Beseitigung jeder
Form von Diskriminierung der Frau sowie
die Beratung des Antrags der Fraktion
Die Linke mit dem Titel Istanbul
Konvention
vorbehaltlos umsetzen für die Dauer der
Aussprache für die Aussprache ist eine
Dauer von 39 Minuten
vereinbart es war gerade ein Freund zu
Versprecher ich eröffne die Aussprache
und erteile und hier wurde jetzt eben
der Tagesordnungspunkt 3 aufgerufen zum
un Übereinkommen zur Frauen
Diskriminierung und was Deutschland
dagegen tut und dazu wird die zuständige
Ministerin als erste sprechen Lisa Pause
werte Kolleginnen werde zuhörende wir
beraten heute den 9 Staatenbericht zum
Übereinkommen der Vereinten Nationen zu
beseitigen Artikel 2 Absatz 3
frauenrechtskonvention
zum einen ist sie das völkerrechtlich
wichtigste Abkommen für die Rechte von
Frauen ihr Auftrag ist unsere Pflicht
auch weil diese Rechte in weiten Teilen
der Welt massiv unter Druck stehen
denken wir zum Beispiel an die Frauen im
Iran die unser aller Solidarität
verdient haben
zum anderen die frauenrechtskonvention
unterstreicht dass die Diskriminierung
von Frauen ein Ausdruck
gesellschaftlicher Machtverhältnis ist
vielleicht formuliert sie das noch
stärker als unser eigenes Grundgesetz
Sie verpflichtet uns tatsächlich die
Gleichstellung aktiv zu fördern das
heißt Bundesregierung Bundestag Länder
Kommunen und Justiz alle sind gefordert
denn sie hat in Deutschland den Rang
eines Bundesgesetzes meine Damen und
Herren
im Mai 2021 hat damal Regierung diesen
neunten Staatenbericht verabschiedet
eine Bilanz was gleichstellungspolitisch
in den vier Jahren zuvor erreicht wurde
also Licht und Schatten und die Mai
kommenden Jahres stehen wir in der
mündlichen Anhörung in Genf dazu Rede
und Antwort unter den kritischen Augen
der Zivilgesellschaft wir nehmen diesen
Prozess sehr ernst und wir haben uns als
Ampelkoalition viel vorgenommen für
diese Legislaturperiode einiges davon
haben wir auch bereits erreicht
ich nenne zwei Beispiele erstens haben
ungewollt Schwangere Frauen mit der
Abschaffung des Paragrafen 219a endlich
Zugang zu wichtigen medizinischen
Informationen zum Abbruch und zweitens
signalisieren wir mit der jetzt
vorbehaltlosen Umsetzung der
istanbul-konvention auch international
dass wir Gewalt gegen Frauen
entschlossen bekämpfen vorher gab es
Vorbehalte gegen einzelparagraphen wir
haben das aufgelöst meine Damen und
Herren
der Deutsche Bundestag befasst sich
heute zum ersten Mal seit sieben Jahren
wieder mit der frauenrechtskonvention
für mich ist die politische Auftrag und
Richtschnur unseres Handelns diese
Bundesregierung
und diese Bundesregierung ist übrigens
die erste die die frauenrechtskonvention
auch in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
verankert hat und darum fördert mein
Haus ab dem 1 Januar auch die
zivilgesellschaftliche sido-allianz in
Deutschland damit die
frauenrechtskonvention noch bekannter
wird und ihre Umsetzung noch
erfolgreicher
ich freue mich auf die Zusammenarbeit
mit Ihnen für Gleichstellung und gegen
die Diskriminierung von Frauen
herzlichen Dank
Lisa Paus die
Familienministerin ja auch zuständig für
Frauen auf sie folgt nun die Obfrau im
Familienausschuss der Unionsfraktion
Katja leikert
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sprechen
heute die Frau Ministerin hat gesagt
über die Umsetzung der UN
frauenrechtskonvention seit knapp
50-seitige Bericht eine Bestandsaufnahme
aus fast allen Bereichen in denen Frauen
heute noch strukturelle
Benachteiligung erfahren und von
Gleichstellung bis Kinderbetreuung sind
das natürlich alles wichtige Themen ich
möchte meine Redezeit aber nutzen um auf
einen Bereich zu zeigen in dem Frauen
mitten in Deutschland eklatante
Menschenrechtsverletzungen erfahren und
ich spreche von hunderttausenden Frauen
in der Prostitution für die zum Alltag
geworden ist von organisierten Banken
Tag für Tag dutzende Male verkauft zu
werden das sind schwerste
Körperverletzung sexuelle Misshandlung
und Freiheitsberaubung die für eine
überwältigende Mehrheit der
Prostituierten in Deutschland leider
ganz normal geworden sind und diese
Frauen
dann in den Bericht und auch in dem was
Sie gesagt haben Frau Paus weitgehend
unsichtbar liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir müssen dringend den Blick
auf diese Situation richten
und wo stehen wir da in Deutschland nach
der Anerkennung von Prostitution als
Dienstleistung von Rot-Rot-Grün vor 20
Jahren haben wir mit mehreren Gesetzen
versucht vergeblich versucht die
Bedingungen für Frauen erträglicher zu
machen zuletzt mit dem sogenannten
Prostituierten Schutzgesetz und
fälschlicherweise unterstellt das Gesetz
dass die Frauen als selbstständige
Unternehmerinnen in diesem Bereich tätig
sind und das obwohl längst bekannt ist
dass Deutschland das Bordell Europas
geworden ist es sind nach dem Gesetz
gerade einmal
24.000 Frauen gemeldet während manche
Experten die tatsächliche Zahl in
Deutschland alleine auf bis zu 700.000
Frauen schätzen
im gesamten
ampelkoalitionsvertrag insbesondere
liebe Kolleginnen schauen sie da mal
rein auf 144 Seiten kommt das Wort
Prostitution nicht ein einziges Mal vor
und entweder haben sie sich mit der
prekären Situation abgefunden oder es
passt nicht in das linke pseudoliberale
Weltbild dass die überwiegende Mehrheit
der Frauen der Prostitution nur unter
Zwang nachgehen und etwa nicht aus
Selbstbestimmung
meine lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich behaupte das nicht Herr Kollege
sondern unterhalten sich einfach mal mit
den Kriminalbeamten und schauen gehen
Sie einfach mal raus und schauen Sie
sich die Situation an gutes Regieren
heißt ideologische Denkweisen auch mal
abzulegen und lassen Sie die Frauen
bitte nicht länger warten sondern
schützen Sie diese wirksam und die
schauen Sie einfach mal über ihren
Tellerrand hinaus in fast keinem Land in
Europa sind Prostitution und der damit
verbundene Menschenhandel so ausgeprägt
wie bei uns in Deutschland es gibt
zahlreiche Länder darunter Schweden
ist meistens bekannt Norwegen Finnland
aber auch Frankreich die sich beim
Schutz von Frauen in diesem Bereich für
das sogenannte nordische Modell
entschieden haben dieses Modell nimmt
die freie in die Pflicht schützt
Prostituierte und fördert gleichzeitig
Ausstiegsmöglichkeiten und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Ampel
in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag verweisen sie
ja gerne auf fortschrittliches
skandinavische Vorbilder machen Sie doch
mal in dem Bereich in dem Frauen immer
noch als wahre gesehen werden dem
Bericht dem Begriff der
fortschrittskoalition wirklich die Ehre
schaut man sich die Entwicklungen vor
Ort in den vergangenen Jahren an und da
würde ich sie wirklich mal auffordern
gehen Sie mal in Berlin in die
Kurfürstenstraße wir waren vor kurzem da
haben uns das angeschaut oder auch in
Frankfurt im Bahnhofsviertel es kommt
kommt einem Tier das Grauen und das
können Sie auch wirklich nicht weg
diskutieren
seien Sie ehrlich zu sich selbst
auch die gut gemeintesten Verbesserungen
beispielsweise in dem Rahmen von dem
Prostituierten Schutzgesetz helfen wenig
in einem Bereich in dem strukturelle
Gewalten die organisierte Ausbeutung von
Frauen zum schrecklichen Alltag geworden
sind
liebe Frau Pause liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen hunderttausende Frauen warten
darauf dass im nächsten Bericht in drei
Jahren gute Fortschritte vom heutigen
Status Quo erkennbar sein werden dazu
haben Sie jetzt die Chance ergreifen Sie
diese vielen Dank
katja alaikat war das und Sie sehen es
schon wir erwarten auch in Kürze eine
Pressekonferenz von Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz der hat sich nämlich mit dem
Ministerpräsidenten von Norwegen janska
stödel im Bundeskanzleramt getroffen und
die beiden werden um Viertel vor so ist
zumindest der Plan dann gemeinsam vor
die Presse steht treten das beobachten
wir natürlich bleiben aber
selbstverständlich so lange im Deutschen
Bundestag der spricht nun Ariane Fischer
für die SPD-Fraktion wir lassen uns die
patriarchiale Idee der menschlichen
Überlegenheit weiterhin viel kosten
alleinpartnerschaftliche Gewalt schlägt
jedes Jahr mit 2,75 Milliarden Euro zu
Buche für Polizei Krankenhaus
Beratungs- und Schutz stellen es gibt
bundesweit 350 Frauenhäuser 100 Schutz
Wohnungen und etwa 600 Beratungsstellen
das Unterstützungsangebot ist aber bei
weitem nicht ausreichend und es gibt
große regionale Unterschiede die
schutzstruktur müsste etwa vierfach so
groß sein so umfangreich sein und vor
allem barrierefrei ausgebaut werden so
mahnt ist der Gremium Bericht an das
wären 11 Milliarden Euro jedes Jahr plus
Baukosten und ohne die Kosten durch
Arbeitsausfälle oder langfristige
Therapie
in Deutschland wird immer noch jede
dritte Frau mindestens einmal in ihrem
Leben Opfer von Psyche physischer oder
sexualisierter Gewalt in allen sozialen
Schichten 9 von 10 Frauen mit
Behinderungen erleben körperliche Gewalt
und sexuelle Übergriffen jeden dritten
Tag stirbt eine Frau weil sie eine Frau
ist durch die Hand ihres Partners oder
Ex-Partners
die Zahlen des Bundeskriminalamtes
zeigen partnerschaftsgewalt in
Deutschland bleibt auf hohem Niveau 2021
wurden 143.604
Opfer partnerschaftlicher Gewalt
polizeilich erfasst vier in vier von
fünf Fällen ist das Opfer eine Frau und
der Täter ein Mann
nur ein Bruchteil der Taten kommt aber
überhaupt zur Anzeige
62% der Minijobber sind Frauen weit mehr
als die Hälfte der Frauen arbeitet den
Teilzeit frauen verdienen über einen
Erwerbsleben betrachtet über 40 Prozent
weniger als Männer und sind doppelt so
oft von Altersarmut bedroht oder
betroffen sogar das Frauen dadurch auch
ökonomisch nach wie vor ein hoher
Abhängigkeit auch in Partnerschaften
stehen schwächt ihre Rolle darin weiter
wir haben uns in der Ampel in diesen
Fragen die Latte hoch gehängt Frau
Ministerin hat schon darauf hingewiesen
wir haben uns im Koalitionsvertrag die
Absicherung des Schutzes jeder Frau
vorgenommen nichts weniger als das ist
unser Anspruch
die Bundesregierung plant eine
dunkelfeldstudie sowie eine
bundesgesetzliche Regelung für Schutz
und Beratung sie arbeitet daran
gemeinsam mit den Ländern und Kommunen
am runden Tisch gemeinsam gegen sexuelle
Gewalt gerade gestern wieder wie als
Bundestagsabgeordnete durften dabei sein
vor einem Monat wurde die unabhängige
berichterstattungsstelle zu
geschlechtsspezifischer Gewalt am
Deutschen Institut für Menschenrechte
eingerichtet diese Maßnahmen lobt auch
der Europäische Rat jedoch mahnt er eine
Koordinierungsstelle auf Bundesebene und
die Entwicklung einer langfristigen
Gesamtstrategie an dringend müssen wir
das Umgangsrecht mit Rücksicht auf die
Interessen von Gewaltopfern reformieren
gesellschaftliche Ungleichheit entsteht
genau wie partnerschaftsgewalt aus
Rollenbildern übersteigerter
Männlichkeit es gilt als männlich stark
beschützend und der Ernährer der Familie
zu sein dazu gehört es dominant und
überlegen mit den abwertend mutig und
auch machtbezogen zu agieren man nimmt
sich was man will
oft gehen diese Bilder damit einher
keine Strategien für den Umgang mit
Krisen mit eigener Schwäche und
Unterlegenheit oder mit Zurückweisung
gelernt zu haben wie geht man ganz
generell mit Gefühlen um
ein echter junge weint nicht ist nur
eine dieser Rollen formen die uns die
Familien und die Gesellschaft mit in der
Lebensweg geben
wer glaubt in jedem Fall der Stärkere zu
sein oder in jedem Fall der stärker sein
zu müssen wird schlussendlich womöglich
das mit Fäusten durchsetzen fast alle
Männer die als Erwachsene gewählt
anwenden haben als Kind Gewalt erlebt
Boris von Heesen beziffert die Kosten
toxischer Männlichkeit mit 65,5
Milliarden Euro jährlich zum Beispiel
sitzen in Gefängnissen 94% Männer Männer
verursachen rund 50% mehr schwere
Verkehrsunfälle ihre Sucht kostet 44
Milliarden Euro
Herr Merz möchte für die Wirtschaft
vorhandene fachkräftepotenziale nutzen
heben habe ich heute morgen gelesen das
ist gute Nachricht denn das Deutsche
Institut für Wirtschaftsforschung hat
ausgerechnet dass die gerechte
Verteilung von kehrarbeit in den
Familien
für Frauen eine gleichberechtige
Teilhabe im Erwerbsleben Sie bitte zum
Schluss
ermöglichen würde das würde 900.000
Arbeits- und Fachkräfte verfügbar machen
gleichberechtigte Männer hätten ein
erfüllteres Leben und eine bessere
Gesundheit höhere Lebenserwartung
[Applaus]
wenn das einer
Ariane Fälscher war das hier wurde
mehrmals aufgefordert sich an die
Redezeit zu halten Sie sehen dass wir
weiten warten weiterhin auf die
Pressekonferenz des Bundeskanzlers und
des Ministerpräsident von Norwegen
nächste Rednerin im Bundestag ist
Marianna ihres harder Kühnel für die
afd-fraktion
die Fußball-WM in Katar führt uns die
bigottie des deutschen ist teppichments
eindrucksvoll vor Augen nimmt man in
einem arabischen Land keine Rücksicht
auf islamische Sitten geht man plötzlich
als weltoffen wendet man sich hingegen
im eigenen Land gegen Verschleierung und
importierte Gewalt gegen Frau gilt man
als Rechtsextremist
das ist in der Unterschied zwischen der
AFD auf der einen und den
kartellparteien auf der anderen Seite
wir respektieren andere Kulturen wollen
aber unsere eigene Kultur bewahren sie
hingegen
Opfern im eigenen Land unsere Kultur zu
Gunsten von anderen Kulturen auf die sie
dann aber im Ausland gar keinen
Rücksicht nehmen ihre Position ist
falsch unsere Position ist richtig es
ist immer noch unser Land in unserem
Land gelten unsere Regeln
unser Land und das ist Frauen
hierzulande oft sehr schlecht geht ist
die Folge dieser mangelnden kulturellen
Selbstbehauptung und das scheint
politisch von ihnen so gewollt zu
belehren sie die Bürger es sei
kultursensibel kein Schweinefleisch mehr
in Kitas anzubieten oder guckt sie fixe
abzuhängen gleichzeitig gehen sie aber
konservativen Gesellschaften im Ausland
mit der Regenbogenflagge auf die Nerven
sie schaden damit den Bürgern im Inland
und blamieren uns im Ausland
eine Kultur die sich selbst nicht
respektiert wird eben auch von anderen
Kulturen nicht respektiert eine solche
Kultur ist dem Untergang geweiht sie
öffnen die Grenzen für jeden Lieferanten
die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft sie
lassen den sozialstand ausgliedern
ausplündern und vor allem machen sie die
eigenen Frauen zu Freiwild die
Frauenhäuser platzen aus allen Nähten
fast 70 Prozent der BewohnerInnen haben
Migrationshintergrund und gegen Frauen
gerichtete Gewalt wird überproportional
häufig von Ausländern begangen bei einem
Ausländeranteil von nur 12 Prozent sind
33 Prozent der Gewalttäter Ausländer
Genitalverstümmelung zwangssehen ermorde
all das ist auf dem Vormarsch all das
wird von ihnen totgeschwiegen denn im
vorliegenden Bericht zur Beseitigung der
Diskriminierung der Frau findet sich zu
alledem genau gar nichts null nada in
diesem Bericht taucht das Wort Islam
nicht ein einziges Mal auf dafür das
Wort gender 81 mal auf 54 Seiten
entsprechend ihre
ihre linke Politik in der Praxis so gibt
die Stadt München für die Umstellung
ihrer IT in gendergerechte Sprache satte
4 Millionen Euro aus 4 Millionen Euro
für Gender Quatsch die dann den völlig
überfüllten Frauenhäusern fehlen es
klingt brutal aber es ist die Wahrheit
die Verhunzung der deutschen Sprache ist
ihnen wichtiger als der Schutz von
Frauen vor brutalen Schlägern
und auch hier im Bundestag kürzt man die
Maßnahmen zur Bekämpfung von Gewalt
gegen Frauen um 10 Millionen Euro
Frauenhäuser sind bundesweit nicht
ausreichend vorhanden und jede vierte
Schutzsuchende Frau musste
2021 Ihren Aufenthalt dort ganz oder
teilweise selber bezahlen gerade die die
sich nicht leisten können sind so der
Gewalt weiterhin ausgeliefert mit ihren
Kindern was für eine politische Bankrott
Erklärung
nachts in den Parks tagsüber in den
Schwimmbädern dort findet die wirkliche
Diskriminierung von Frauen statt weil
sie sich dort nicht mehr hintrauen weil
sie dort oft als verfügbare [ __ ]
misshandelt werden weil sie dort häufig
als Menschen zweiter Klasse gelten das
ist importierte frauengewalt hier gegen
es anzukämpfen und zwar in Deutschland
und nicht in Katar kommst Du bitte zum
Schluss
[Applaus]
Position beträgt in Deutschland wir
kriegen 29% in angeblich so
konservativen Polen satte
43%, wenn sie jetzt nicht zum Schluss
kommen
[Musik]
mit dem moralischen Finger auf andere zu
zeigen dass dort immer drei Finger auf
sie vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und für die FDP-Fraktion hat das Wort
die Kollegin Nicole Bauer Nicole Bauer
Sprecherin für Frauenpolitik und
diversity ihrer Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Liebe
Ministerin Paulus werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich sage aller Klarheit
Frauenrechte sind Menschenrechte und sie
sind unverhandelbar
und doch sehen wir aktuell in der Welt
die Unterdrückung von Frauen die
Bedrohung von Leben und die Verachtung
von Freiheit durch brutale Regime
tapfere Menschen gehen mit dem Einsatz
ihres Lebens auf die Straße um für ihre
Rechte zu kämpfen und gegen ihre
Unterdrücker wir alle stehen gerade in
diesen Tagen an der Seite der Menschen
im Iran
wie als Freie Demokraten treten dafür
ein für eine Welt in der Frauen frei
sicher und selbstbestimmt leben können
ohne dass sie von patriarchischen
Strukturen unterdrückt werden und das
gilt natürlich auch für die Frauen auf
der Flucht Frauen und Kinder aus der
Ukraine suchen aktuell Schutz bei uns
weil sie mit unter schlimmste gewalte
Erfahrungen letzten Monaten erleben
mussten wenn wir also Diskriminierung
ernst nehmen dann müssen wir Gewalt
gegen Frauen ganz oben auf die Agenda
setzen
und dabei dürfen wir nicht vergessen
dass es auch Gewalt gegen Frauen
hierzulande gibt in unserer
Nachbarschaft in Familien und am
Arbeitsplatz die Kriminalstatistik zur
partnerschaftsgewalt aus der vergangenen
Woche spiegelt das wieder
2021 gab es allein
143.000 Fälle von Gewalt in
Partnerschaften 80 und wir verlassen die
Bundestagsdebatte kurzweilig zumindest
um der Pressekonferenz von Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz und Herr störe zu lauschen
früher als die
lieber Jonas herzlichen Dank für Deinen
Besuch heute hier in Berlin mal wieder
es ist ja schon unser drittes
persönliches Treffen in diesem Jahr
zweimal hier in Berlin einmal bei dir in
osloh was ein deutlicher Beleg sein mag
für den engen Austausch den Norwegen und
Deutschland miteinander haben die
aktuellen Herausforderungen haben unsere
Länder noch enger zusammenrücken lassen
und das ist gut so Deutschland und
Norwegen haben gemeinsame Werte und
gemeinsame Positionen Demokratie
Rechtsstaatlichkeit die Achtung der
Menschenrechte so der Glaube an
Diplomatie und Multilateralismus
höheren Bund und Länder zweitens eine
sichere Finanzierung von Frauenhäusern
um mehr Plätze diese müssen aber
barrierefrei sein sowie eine
präventions- und Täterarbeit die
ausgebaut werden muss ebenso wie mehr
Sensibilisierung und
Aufklärungskampagnen und eine extrem
wichtige Schritt an dieser Stelle hat
unser Bundesjustizminister Marco
Buschmann bereits gemacht Paragraf 46
aus dem Strafgesetzbuch soll geändert
werden und geschlechterspezifische
Gewalt künftig stärker bestraft werden
meine Damen und Herren
Diskriminierung von Frauen findet nicht
nur in geschlechterspezifische Gewalt
statt nein seit der Ratifizierung der
Abkommens gibt es seit 1985 ist
sicherlich viel passiert aber es gibt
eben noch viel zu viel zu tun denn um
echte gelebte Chancengleichheit in
unserem Land von Männer und Frauen zu
bekommen ist noch viel viel zu tun es
sind sicherlich schon einige Maßnahmen
aus dem Koalitionsvertrag umgesetzt wie
beispielsweise die Abschaffung von 219a
damit ist ein sehr wichtiger Meilenstein
gelungen aber es werden auch noch
weitere Meilensteine Folgen
beispielsweise in der Vereinbarkeit von
Familie und Beruf ein herzensthema
meinerseits wir diskutieren aktuell ein
Paket für mehr Partnerschaftlichkeit und
dieses Paket was wir uns da vorstellen
geht weit über die Anpassungen in der
vereinbarkeitsrichtlinie und der
Umsetzung dieser hinaus für mich ist
dabei besonders wichtig und das sage ich
bewusst als eine frisch gebackene Mutter
der flexible zwei Wochen
partnerschutz nach der Geburt
Mutterschutz muss ebenso auch für
Selbstständige möglich sein und
Elterngeld und Elternzeit muss endlich
flexibilisiert und entbürokratisiert
werden
also meine Damen und Herren treten wir
gemeinsam dafür ein dass mehr
Chancengleichheit zur Lebensrealität von
allen Menschen in unserem Land wird
deutschlandweit und weltweit ganz im
Sinne Frauen Freiheit Menschenrechte
herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Nachwuchs
liebe Frau Bauer
und für die Fraktion DIE LINKE hat das
Wort Heidi Reicheneck
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen am letzten Freitag dem Tag
zur Beseitigung von Gewalt gegen Frauen
haben zahlreiche Abgeordnete
kämpferische Fotos in den sozialen
Medien gepostet oder orange getragen um
auf die Bedeutung dieses Tages
aufmerksam zu machen aus den Reihen der
koalitionsfraktion hieß es im Rahmen der
Haushaltsberatung auch jetzt brauche es
mehr als Symbolpolitik es müssen endlich
Taten folgen und das ist absolut richtig
denn
jede dritte Frau in Deutschland er fährt
im Laufe ihres Lebens körperliche oder
sexualisierte Gewalt bei Frauen mit
Behinderung ist das Risiko dreimal höher
noch immer wird jeden zweiten bis
dritten Tag eine Frau von ihrem Partner
oder Ex-Partner ermordet und das
schockierendste an diesen Zahlen ist
dass sie sich nicht ändern das nichts
passiert und der sido Bericht sagt auch
ziemlich deutlich woran das liegt er
kritisiert nämlich dass Deutschland
immer noch keine umfassende
Präventionsstrategie hat im Kampf gegen
Gewalt an Frauen
nun ist dieser Bericht schon vom letzten
Jahr damals hatten wir noch keine
ampelregierung sondern eine große
Koalition und die hat dann zu diesem
Vorwurf gesagt doch die haben wir
schließlich sehr die istanbulkommission
2018 in Kraft getreten und das da ja
nach deutschem Verfassungsrecht nur
möglich wenn die Anforderung der
Konvention im nationalen Recht bereits
erfüllt sein kontrolliert werde dies von
der grevio-kommission wir haben das
gerade schon gehört Thema erledigt für
die groko jetzt hat die
grevio-kommission aber gerade einen
neuen Bericht veröffentlicht und da sagt
sie Überraschung Deutschland erfüllt die
Anforderung eben nicht das hat aber die
neue Koalition auch erkannt und sich in
ihren Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben dass
sie die Istan bekommen vorbehaltlos und
wirksam umsetzen will die Vorbehalte
werden zum Februar zurückgezogen das ist
zu begrüßen kostet ja aber auch nicht
nichts wirksam würde hingegen bedeuten
dass Mittel in die Hand genommen werden
müssen um notwendige Strukturen zu
schaffen und davon haben wir im Haushalt
leider nichts gesehen im Gegenteil
die Koalition schreibt auch in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag wir berücksichtigen
die Bedarfe wohl eine radlergruppen wie
Frauen mit Behinderung und die
Konsequenz sehen wir das Bundesprogramm
zum Ausbau von Frauenhäusern und
beratungsplätzen wurde von 30 auf 20
Millionen gekürzt eine Kürzung von 30
Prozent genau in dem Programm mit dem
diese Angebote für Frauen mit
Behinderung zugänglich gemacht werden
sollen dabei ist die Ampel sonst bei
Mitteln für den Aufbau von Gebäuden gar
nicht so knifflig in das
Bundeskanzleramt Punkt sie schließlich
770 Millionen
weil nach über einem Jahr immer noch
viel zu wenig passiert ist legen wir
heute einen Antrag für die
Bundesregierung dazu auffordert endlich
zu handeln wir brauchen ein Nationalen
Aktionsplan eine Koordinierungsstelle
mit angemessenen finanziellen und
personellen Ressourcen und einen
Gesetzesentwurf der dafür sorgt dass die
fehlenden 14.000 Frauen Hausplätze ich
sag's noch mal über 14.000
frauenhausplätze finden in diesem Land
dass die endlich aufgebaut werden
Bilder in den sozialen Medien schaffen
vielleicht Aufmerksamkeit aber sie lösen
nicht die strukturellen Probleme und um
diese strukturellen Probleme zu lösen
sind wir eigentlich hier deswegen nehmen
Sie mal Geld in die Hand machen sie das
was sie fordern nämlich was anderes als
im wohlpolitik unterstützen Sie unseren
Antrag der sido-bericht zeigt
es wird Zeit stürzen wir das Patriarchat
und für Bündnis 90 die Grünen hat das
Wort Denise Lob
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen schon vor über 36 Jahren hat
Deutschland die Menschenrechtskonvention
sie da ratifiziert sie widmet sich der
Beseitigung aller Form von
Diskriminierung gegen Frauen sie
verpflichtet die Vertragsstaaten zu
rechtlichen und faktischen
Gleichstellungen in allen
Lebensbereichen dieser Verpflichtung ist
Deutschland bisher allerdings nicht
ausreichend nachgekommen das wurde schon
2017 durch die UN frauenrechtskonvention
festgestellt und auf zwei zentrale
Kritikpunkte möchte ich hier besonders
eingehen
erster die deutsche Regelung zum
Schwangerschaftsabbruch im
Strafgesetzbuch denn sie bedeutet dass
ungewollt Schwangere immer noch
kriminalisiert stigmatisiert und in
ihrer körperlichen Selbstbestimmung
eingeschränkt werden auch die damit
verbundene Pflicht Beratung die Tatsache
dass die Krankenversicherung die Kosten
für einen Abbruch nicht übernehmen und
die prekäre Versorgungslage sind Folgen
dieser Kriminalisierung aus dem
aktuellen Bericht und ich möchte noch
mal auf meine Kollegin Frau leikert
eingehen das ist ein Bericht der letzten
Regierung wird deutlich dass die
Vorgängerregierung nichts unternommen
hat um das Recht auf ein
selbstbestimmten Schwangerschaftsabbruch
zu gewährleisten
die Kritik des frauenrechtsausschuss der
UN die Forderung der WHO die
Verpflichtung aus dem ratifizierten
Abkommen wurden einfach ignoriert der so
notwendige und wichtige Fortschritt bei
reproduktiver Selbstbestimmung
verschlafen doch damit ist jetzt endlich
Schluss wir als Ampelkoalition wir gehen
die vielen überfälligen
gleichstellungspolitischen Vorhaben an
das hat unsere Gleichstellungsministerin
dieser Paus vorhin schon deutlich
gemacht
und ein erster Erfolg ist die Streichung
des § 219a aus dem Strafgesetzbuch wir
haben den Zugang zu Informationen zum
Schwangerschaftsabbruch und die
rechtliche Lage von Ärztinnen endlich
verbessert doch dabei dürfen wir nicht
stehen bleiben als nächster Schritt muss
die Kommission zur reproduktiven Rechten
und Fortpflanzungsmedizin eingesetzt
werden unser Ziel ist es dass Frauen
endlich selbstbestimmt über ihren Körper
und ihr Leben entscheiden können
ein zweiter zentraler Kritikpunkt des
sido-ausschusses ist der Schutz vor
Gewalt für alle Frauen auch diese
Verpflichtung von der auch diese
Verpflichtung wurde von der vorregierung
nur mangelhaft umgesetzt aber wir haben
endlich wesentliche Schritte eingeleitet
wir haben eine staatliche
Koordinierungsstelle im
gleichstellungsministerium eingerichtet
die eine ressortübergreifende nationale
Strategie für gewaltschutz erarbeitet
auch die unabhängige
berichterstattungsstelle für
geschlechtsspezifische Gewalt im
Deutschen Institut für Menschenrechte
hat ihre Arbeit aufgenommen und wird
überprüfen ob Deutschland die
internationalen Vorgaben wirklich
effektiv umsetzt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Beseitigung aller Form von
Diskriminierung gegen Frauen zu der sich
Deutschland mit dem Unterzeichnen von
Seedorf verpflichtet hat können wir nur
erreichen wenn Frauen endlich auch in
ihrem Recht auf reproduktive
Selbstbestimmung gestärkt werden und ein
Leben frei von Gewalt führen können hier
werden die als Ampelkoalition zügig
vorangehen vielen Dank
und für die Unionsfraktion hat das Wort
die Kollegin Mareike Lotte Wolf
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren in diesen
Tagen läuft die Fußball-WM in Katar und
vor ein paar Tagen rannte ein Mann auf
das Spielfeld während des Spiels
Portugal gegen Uruguay auf seinem
T-Shirt stand Respekt vor the woman of
Iran
Frauen stehen derzeit im Mittelpunkt
einer politischen Bewegung im Iran die
sich gegen ein Terrorregime auflehnt ein
Regime das Frauen seit über 40 Jahren im
Namen der Religion unterdrückt mit
martialischen Strafen und sexualisierter
Folter belegt oder wie im Falle von Gina
Massa Amini tötet
kein Beispiel macht deutlicher und da
gebe ich Ihnen recht liebe Frau Bauer
Frauenrechte sind Menschenrechte und wir
als demokratische Gesellschaften müssen
uns immer an der Umsetzung der Rechte
der Frauen messen lassen
der c-dav-bericht zur Umsetzung der
UN-Konvention zum Verbot der
Diskriminierung von Frauen ist eben
Ausdruck davon und die letzte
Bundesregierung hat diesen Auftrag ernst
genommen in den letzten fünf Jahren
wurden unter anderem umgesetzt eine
ressortübergreifende
gleichstellungsstrategie die Einrichtung
einer Bundesstiftung Gleichstellung und
besonders wichtig die Aufwertung der
sozialen Berufe
die UN das was die UN von der
Bundesregierung will kommt auch in
unserem Artikel 3 die Ministerin hat die
ihnen schon erwähnt Absatz zwei
Grundgesetz zum Ausdruck man könnte auch
sagen walk the talk es ist ein Bericht
der den tatsächlichen Fortschritt über
die Umsetzung der Gleichstellung von
Frauen eben dokumentiert und das ist
sehr viel Arbeit ist es glaube ich
unumstritten und deshalb möchte ich auch
einmal allen im Ministerium Beteiligten
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern für
diese mühevolle Arbeit danken
speziell möchte ich auf den Bereich der
Bildung und der Arbeit eingehen die gute
Nachricht ist dass es nur auch keine
neue Nachricht der Zugang zum
Bildungssystem in Deutschland ist für
Frauen nicht nur im gleichen Maße
gewährleistet sie schneiden sogar leicht
besser ab seit 1992 haben jährlich mehr
Mädchen als Jungen die Schule mit dem
Abitur erlassen 2020 waren über 50
Prozent der Studienberechtigten weiblich
in dem Bericht fehlt mir persönlich ein
schlaglich auf die duale
Berufsausbildung und ich möchte
diejenigen die den Bericht erstellen
bitten einen stärkeren Fokus auf genau
dieses Thema zu legen denn es ist eine
Besonderheit des deutschen oder
deutschsprachigen Bildungssystems die
ganz stark zur Bildungsgerechtigkeit
eben beiträgt und das müssen wir aus
meiner Sicht gerade international immer
wieder betonen weil natürlich nicht so
explizit danach gefragt wird
während der Zugang zur Bildung
unumstritten gewährleistet ist haben wir
aber große Unterschiede bei der
geschlechtsifischen Berufswahl und
deshalb ist es aus meiner Sicht gut dass
die vergangene Bundesregierung einen
großen Fokus auf die Frauenberufe die
sogenannten Frauenberufe gelegt hat in
der Pflege wir wissen hier ist der
Anteil der Frauen zum Teil bis zu 95
Prozent das Pflegeberufe Reformgesetz
die Kontext konzertierte Aktion Pflege
die ausbildungsaktion Pflege das waren
alles Initiativen die auf den Weg
gebracht wurden und die zu recht positiv
bewertet werden
aber was passiert jetzt
mit Verlauf Frau Ministerin seit die
Grünen das Ministerium übernommen haben
fehlt uns jegliche frauenpolitische
Initiative sie ist nicht mehr zu
beobachten dabei haben sie einen ganz
klaren Auftrag jetzt für die Frauen in
der Krise in Deutschland einzutreten
gerade in den sogenannten Frauenberufen
ist diese Regierung mit zweierlei Maß
der Pflege Bonus wird eben nicht an alle
Frauen ausgezahlt die auf einer
Pflegestation und medizinischen Bereich
arbeiten warum haben sie sich nicht
dafür stark gemacht dass eben auch die
Hebammen oder die pflegeassistenzen
einen Pflegeberuf bekommen warum sind
die einfach ausgenommen das versteht im
Krankenhaus wirklich niemand und ist
gefährdet eben auch den
innerbetrieblichen Frieden in diesen
Einrichtungen
auch in der aktuellen Energiekrise sind
Frauen ganz besonders betroffen und
deshalb würde ich mir mehr Aktion von
ihnen wünschen Frau Kraus unseren Antrag
zur Verbesserung der Situation von
Alleinerziehende wir haben sie einfach
abgelehnt ich habe mit Alleinerziehenden
gesprochen die mir gesagt haben sie
überlegen ihren Beruf ihre
Berufstätigkeit in Teilzeit jetzt
aufzugeben weil dann die Energiekosten
und eben auch der Nachhilfeunterricht
übernommen werden das können wir doch
nicht akzeptieren und wenn sie mir jetzt
sagen na ja das dritte Entlastungspaket
das hat Verbesserung gebracht dann muss
ich leider das Dew zitieren und das sind
ja nur nicht immer nur unsere Freunde
aber dass die wie gesagt ganz klar
Alleinerziehende Normalverdiener haben
am wenigsten von diesem Entlastungspaket
profitiert liebe Frau ist meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren lassen sie
Frauen in dieser Krise eben nicht allein
es trifft sie sonst mit doppelter Wucht
und auf diesen Doppels wollen Frauen in
diesem Land nun wirklich verzichten
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
Josephine
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe Frau
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die UN frauenrechts Konvention
kurz sido steht für viele Gesichter für
die Rentnerin die von Altersarmut
betroffen ist obwohl sie ihr Leben lang
gearbeitet hat für die Frau mit
Rollstuhl die nicht ins Frauenhaus kann
weil das eben nicht barrierefrei ist und
für die alleinerziehende Kassiererin die
nicht arbeiten kann weil die
Öffnungszeiten der Kita eben nicht zu
den Öffnungszeiten des Supermarktes
passen diese Beispiele zeigen wir müssen
unseren Anspruch an eine
gleichberechtigte Gesellschaft endlich
mit der Realität zusammenbringen
sido ist da auch ganz klar gleiche
Rechte reichen dabei eben nicht was
zählt ist die Lebensrealität und damit
die tatsächlichen Verbesserungen für die
für das Leben von Frauen wir wollen
Fakten schaffen denn es kommt auf das
Endergebnis an das ist mein Anspruch und
das ist unser Anspruch als SPD-Fraktion
der
9 Staatenbericht spricht für sich wir
konnten in der letzten Legislaturperiode
mit einem SPD-geführten
Frauenministerium viele gute Projekte
anstoßen und das trotz der Union trotz
der Union haben wir das
führungspositionengesetz erweitert trotz
der Union haben wir Verbesserungen in
der Kinderbetreuung durch das Gute
Kita-Gesetz hinbekommen und trotz der
Union haben wir die Grundrente
geschaffen die mehrheitlich Frauen hilft
und
in der Ampel können wir jetzt endlich
weitergehen und es ist noch mehr möglich
werden die Istanbul Konvention
vorbehaltlos umsetzen
Antidiskriminierungsarbeit stärken die
Besteuerung geschlechtergerecht
gestalten Verhütung für viel mehr freien
Frauen kostenfrei zugänglich machen und
einen gleichstellungsscheck einführen
das sind echte Verbesserungen für die
Lebensrealitäten von Frauen
die UN frauenrechtskonvention hat aber
nicht nur ein weibliches Gesicht sondern
auch ein männliches zum Beispiel der
Vater der sich für eine Vollzeitstelle
entscheidet obwohl er lieber weniger
arbeiten würde oder der junge Mann der
sich vorstellen könnte Erzieher zu
werden sich aber dafür entscheidet die
Ausbildung zum Industriemechaniker zu
machen hinter diesen Entscheidungen
stehen natürlich finanzielle Anreize
aber auch immer und leider noch viel zu
oft stehen dahinter Stereotype und
geschlechterliches Sieder ist auch hier
sehr deutlich wenn wir
Geschlechtergerechtigkeit erreichen
wollen müssen wir diese über kommenden
Rollenmuster endlich aufbrechen
und die UN
frauenrechtskonvention hat aber auch
viele internationale Gesichter eines
dieser Gesichter und wir haben den Namen
schon gehört ist Massa Gina Amini an
ihrem Schicksal sehen wir ganz deutlich
was es bedeutet wenn Frauenrechte nicht
anerkannt werden der Iran ist eines der
wenigen Länder weltweit dass sie da
nicht beigetreten ist deutschland muss
sich in den geeigneten Gremien der UN
für die Menschen für die Frauen im Iran
einsetzen deswegen bin ich froh dass der
un- Menschenrechtsrat auf Initiative von
Deutschland hin eine unabhängige
Untersuchung der Gewalt im Iran
beschlossen hat die Frauen im Iran
zeigen mit ihren Protesten dass
Frauenrechte Menschenrechte sind sie
zeigen dass die Freiheit einer
Gesellschaft erst durch die Freiheit von
Frauen erreichbar wird die Frauen im
Iran verteidigen gerade die Rechte von
Frauen weltweit was wir tun können ist
für sie laut zu sein
mit unseren Stimmen ihren Mut in die
Welt zu tragen für mich ist klar wenn
wir Frauen zusammenstehen wird die Welt
eine bessere vielen Dank
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
Heike engelhardt
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Frau
Ministerin Pauls liebe Kolleginnen und
liebe Schülerinnen hier im Haus heute
noch immer werden Frauen strukturell
benachteiligt diskriminiert ausgegrenzt
sind von geschlechtsbezogener Gewalt
betroffen
wir haben schon viele Anstrengungen
unternommen dies zu beseitigen aber wir
müssen besser werden das schulden wir
allen Frauen in unserem Land es ist
wichtig dass ein
gleichstellungspolitischer Plan in einen
europäischen und internationalen Rahmen
eingebettet ist Deutschland sollte in
diesem Bereich als Vorbild handeln
können
aber um international für Frauenrechte
einstehen zu können müssen wir erst hier
Ungerechtigkeiten und Diskriminierung
beseitigen und deswegen ist es nämlich
richtig dass wir die istanbul-konvention
in unserem Koalitionsvertrag
festgeschrieben haben und dass wir auch
heute hier im Plenum darüber sprechen
ich bin
ich bin froh über Maßnahmen gegen Gewalt
an Frauen und gleichzeitig brauchen wir
Maßnahmen für gleichberechtigte
Beteiligung wir haben jetzt die
Gelegenheit international Standards zu
setzen auch in der Parlamentarischen
Versammlung des Europarates setzen sich
die demokratischen Fraktionen für mehr
Frauenrechte ein zum Beispiel wurde im
Oktober auf die hohe Diskriminierung von
Frauen im Sport hingewiesen Frauen haben
im Sport schlechte
Zugangsvoraussetzungen verdienen als
Sportlerinnen weniger als Männer sind
sexueller Gewalt ausgesetzt und sind oft
nicht angemessen vertreten in den
Verbänden gerade jetzt im Zusammenhang
mit der
Fußballweltmeisterschaft müssen wir
wieder auf Frauenrechte hinweisen denn
am Ende zählt Frauenrechte sind
Menschenrechte vielen Dank
so weit die Pressekonferenz von so weit
die Pressekonferenz von Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz im mit dem
Ministerpräsidenten aus Norwegen
Jonas gar störe hier im Bundeskanzleramt
und damit kommen wir zurück zum
Bundestag der Debatte über den Bericht
zum
heftigen jetzt sehen sie gerade das
Beschäftigen ihre Plätze Räumen und wir
haben jetzt einige Innenpolitiker die
nun hier Platz nehmen denn es geht um
waldbrandschutz und Waldbrand Bekämpfung
die CDU CSU-Fraktion und die Fraktion
DIE LINKE haben dazu jeweils einen
Antrag vorgelegt in dem sie fordern die
Kraft Anstrengung für einen
waldbrandschutz noch mal zu
intensivieren die Unionsfraktion fordert
zum Beispiel
das Drohnen Video und Satellitentechnik
sowie kleinen Flugzeuge beschafft werden
um eben eine um Waldbrände präventiv zu
erkennen und und dann auch sie zu
löschen mit löschhubschraubern und
Flugzeugen die Linksfraktion fordert
eine Luft verlegbare
brandbekämpfungseinheit die eben
Waldbrände bekämpfen soll und für die
Unionsfraktion spricht nun auch als
erstes mechthilde Wittmann aus der
Unionsfraktion und Mitglied im Ausschuss
für Inneres und Heimat
Sachsen-Anhalt Frau Staatssekretärin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir stellen
Ihnen heute einen Antrag vor zu
nationalen Kraftanstrengung für einen
besseren waldbrandschutz und ich glaube
dieses ist ein Antrag der uns in Summe
hier im Haus vereint nämlich dass wir
alle wissen dass Wald eines der
ökologischen Systeme ist die für uns
jetzt am wichtigsten ist zum Klimaschutz
für das ökologische Gleichgewicht
übrigens auch für die Bewirtschaftung
und auch als großer CO2-Speicher den wir
all umfassend hier im Land und überall
brauchen Sie wissen vielleicht dass wir
in 2019 einen Rekord hatten an
Waldbränden was uns nicht gut getan hat
denn sie wissen die Vegetationszeit die
der Umschlag braucht bis so einen
verbranntes Gebiet bis so verbrannte
Strecke wieder aufgeforstet werden kann
kann Jahrzehnte dauern bei Kieferwald
Monokulturen die wir uns ohnehin nicht
wünschen aber bis zu 100 Jahren meine
Damen und Herren deswegen wollen wir sie
jetzt animieren und dafür werben dass
sie diesem Antrag mit beitreten können
indem wir darum bitten dass wir die
Dinge einmal kurz betrachten wir haben
eine feuergefährdung durch den Menschen
im übrigen ist die Brandstiftung eines
der Hauptursachen dass es überhaupt zu
Waldbrand kommt sei sie fahrlässig oder
vorsätzlich für Last wir haben vorher
begünstigt eine Faktoren dazu gehört
Totholz todholzte Wälder mit Totholz
haben unter anderem auch eine hemmende
Wirkung bei der Waldbrand Bekämpfung wir
haben vergras gewaltbestände und wir
haben durch Schädlingsbefall und das
wissen wir dass immer Heft hier wird in
diesen Zeiten eine enorme Gefährdung
dafür dass diese Faktoren diese Feuer
begünstigenden Faktoren Faktoren
entstehen gleichzeitig haben wir
brandbekämpfungserschwerende Faktoren
das sind wie ich schon sagte der massive
totholzbestand aber auch
unzugängliche Flächen weil wir eben Wege
haben die diesen nicht zugänglich sind
weil sich unsere Feuerwehren dem nicht
nähern können und es damit die
Bekämpfung eines Brandes die Eindämmung
wenn er denn entstanden ist umso
schwerer macht und auch hier müssen wir
dann das gleiche gilt für die
munitionsbelastung die wir übrigens
hauptsächlich hier in den Wäldern rund
um Berlin in Brandenburg immer noch
haben und insgesamt demografische
Unzulänglichkeit die ich Ihnen aus dem
alten Rand genauso schildern kann in
gebirgigen Gebirge gegen den all dieses
hat uns veranlasst heute zu sagen ich
glaube wir müssen ein bisschen mehr
zusammen helfen also nur auf die
Kommunen mit ihren freiwilligen zu
verlassen wir wissen die Freiwilligen
Feuerwehren sind eigentlich unsere
Rückgrat derzeit dazu dass wir bei der
Brandbekämpfung keine großen
Schwierigkeiten haben aber wenn der
Brand größer wird
kommen sie nicht näher ran als 500 Meter
dann geht es um eine andere Art von
Bekämpfung dafür brauchen wir
Löschflugzeuge Drohnen Drohnen zu
Beobachtung aber auch zur Bekämpfung und
entsprechende Löschhubschrauber und
meine Damen und Herren hier können wir
die Kommunen und die Länder nicht
alleine lassen hier müssen wir gemeinsam
handeln und hier ist der Bund jetzt
gefragt
und deswegen Kolleginnen und Kollegen
darf ich noch mal darum werben dass wir
hier gemeinsam nicht sparen bei der beim
Katastrophenschutz nicht sparen bei
unseren THW die wir dafür brauchen nicht
sparen bei der Bundeswehr die auch
national gebraucht wird so dass
insgesamt koordiniert werden kann dass
wir brandflächen schnell eindämmen
können und natürlich brauchen wir eine
entsprechende Prävention dafür bedarf
ist der Zusammenarbeit zwischen den
staatswäldern aber auch den privaten
Waldbesitzern denn sie sind auch ganz
wesentlich dass sie ihre Wälder so
schützen aber auch in ihre
Bewirtschaftung so aufstellen ich denke
da an die Beendigung der Monokulturen
und ein Aufbau der Blender
Waldwirtschaft damit diese möglichst
resilienter gegen sind das Brandt sich
ausbreiten kann und deswegen meine Damen
und Herren würde ich mich sehr freuen
wenn wir dieses gemeinsam in diesem
Hause verabschieden würden und hier
gemeinsam zusammenraufen könnten denn
Waldbrand ist nichts was irgendwer will
und letztendlich will jeder von uns
jetzt dann ich glaube seinen
Adventskranz sehen einen kleinen
Weihnachtsbaum möglich Art und Weise ein
gut duftenden aus eigenen Wäldern haben
vor allen Dingen aber auch Erholung und
Schutz in den Wäldern suchen für uns
selber auch für die Tiere die dort leben
und schließlich unendlich für die
vielfältige Natur die sich dort
ausbreitet und deswegen darf ich Sie
herzlich bitten uns im Antrag
zuzustimmen vielen Dank
fordert im mechthilde Wittmann hier in
der Debatte zum
waldbrandschutz in vier von zehn Fällen
ist übrigens die Brandursache in den
Wäldern nachweislich auf fahrlässiges
oder vorsätzliches Verhalten von
Menschen zu führen Ingo Schäfer spricht
nun für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Gäste sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich habe den
Eindruck dass wir alle das Problem
erkannt haben wenn sowohl die
Unionsfraktion als auch die Linke
Anträge zum Thema Waldbrände in
Deutschland anbringen scheint dies ein
wichtiges Thema als wichtiges Thema
angekommen zu sein den Jahren 2018 und
2019 insgesamt rund 5000 Hektar Wald in
Deutschland
wir alle sehen jedes Jahr was uns das
Bundesumweltamt anhand von Statistiken
für uns bereitstellt und festgestellt
hat nämlich die Waldbrandgefahr steigt
die Bundesanstalt für Landwirtschaft und
Ernährung verzeichnet für das Jahr 2021
bundesweit 548 Waldbrände mehr als die
Hälfte mit unbekannter Ursachen von März
bis Oktober brannte irgendwo in
Deutschland immer ein Stück Wald die
Waldbrandgefahr besteht also nahezu
ganzjährig und kaum ein Bunde bekommen
ein Bundesland bleibt verschont
wir können auch feststellen ohne die
Amtshilfe des Bundes sind die schweren
Waldbrände nicht zu löschen Bundeswehr
und Bundespolizei haben im vergangenen
Jahr ein Nordrhein-Westfalen Brandenburg
und Sachsen geholfen Waldbrände zu
löschen für jeden größeren Waldbrand
sind neben den Feuerwehren auch die
Helferinnen und Helfer des THW im
Einsatz
aber es reicht
sie sind eine notwendige Ergänzung des
Katastrophenschutz der Länder hinzu
kommen die Fähigkeiten vom Bundespolizei
im Bundeswehr zwar waren die
Polizeihubschrauber des Landes NRW beim
Waldbrand im Sauerland im Sommer im
Einsatz aber es reicht offenbar nicht
aus der Katastrophenschutz in
Deutschland ist auf der Bundespolizei
und auf die Bundeswehr angewiesen die
Bundeswehr verfügt über 159 Hubschrauber
die für Löscharbeiten aus der Luft in
Frage kommen die Bundespolizei unterhält
fast 80 Hubschrauber allerdings ihre
Tragfähigkeit der leichten Transporter
ist sehr beschränkt
deshalb ist es ausdrücklich zu begrüßen
dass die Innenministerin Nancy Faeser
sehr frühzeitig in ihrer Amtszeit
entschieden hat die neu zu beschaffenden
44 Transporthubschrauber für die
Bundespolizei mit Winden für
Personenrettung und die
Aufnahmemöglichkeit verlöschwasser und
außenlastbehälter auszustatten der
Doppelnutzen ist offensichtlich sie
dienen der Aufgaben der Bundespolizei
und Sie können dem Notfall zur
Menschenrettung und für die
Brandbekämpfung von Wald und
wiesenbrennen eingesetzt werden
wichtig ist mir dass die Bundesregierung
in Zukunft eine Bereitschaft für den
Bevölkerungsschutz einrichtet die im
Rahmen der Amtshilfe des Bundes in der
Not sofort verfügbar ist zum Beispiel
zur Brandbekämpfung bei Waldbränden oder
bei flugkatastrophen wie im Ahrtal
diese tragöde darf uns nicht darf ich
nicht wiederholen die Fähigkeiten müssen
verfügbar sein und es muss klar sein wer
über ihren Einsatz entscheidet
schließlich muss es ein schnelles
Entscheidungsverfahren geben in der Not
können wir nicht stundenlang warten bis
die Anträge einer Kommune über die
Bezirksregierung über die
Landesministerien zur Bundesregierung
und wieder zurückgelaufen ist also
nochmal ohne die Amtshilfe des Bundes
nicht
ein weiteres gutes Beispiel für den
Doppelnutzen sind die Löschflugzeuge die
die Bundesregierung nun beschafft im
Sommer brauchten wir Löschflugzeuge aus
Italien und hat zwei Brände aus der Luft
zu kämpfen zu können
die Europäische Union finanziert
Löschhubschrauber und Löschflugzeuge
über ihre katastrophenschutzverfahren
die bisherigen Innenminister haben sich
die bei diesem Programm nicht beteiligt
auch das hat unsere Innenminister Nancy
fazer
sorry
auch das hat unsere
zusammen mit dem Kollegen aus
Niedersachsen Boris Pistorius geändert
Deutschland wird
Deutschland wird sie EU-Programm mit
zwei Löschflugzeugen beteiligen das ist
gut für die europäische Solidarität und
es ist gut für unser Land wenn wieder
mal großflächige Waldbrände entstehen
der doppelten für unsere EU-Politik und
dem Bevölkerungsschutz liegt auf der
Hand sehr geehrte Damen und Herren wir
sind politisch verantwortlich dafür
bestmöglich vorzusorgen
wir sind auch verantwortlich dafür dass
viele tausend Helferinnen und Helfer in
den nächsten Notsituationen besser
ausgerüstet und vorbereitet sind und wir
sind verantwortlich dafür aus den
Fehlern der Vergangenheit zu lernen
Bevölkerungsschutz bedeutet dass wir uns
alle auf alle Eventualitäten bestmöglich
vorbereiten und das wird die
Ampelkoalition auch in der nicht
polizeilichen Gefahrenabwehr leisten
in dem vergangenen zwei Jahren haben wir
kräftig in den Bevölkerungsschutz
investiert gemeinsam mit den Ländern
haben wir das gemeinsame
Kompetenzzentrum Bevölkerungsschutz
aufgebaut das gkopp ist die Keimzelle
dafür dass Bund und Länder in Zukunft
gemeinsam den Schutz der Bevölkerung
gewährleisten können das gkopp wird sich
in einem effizienten
Ressourcenmanagement beteiligen und
kümmern
und wenn ich von wir spreche da meine
ich Bund und Länder und wir haben eine
geteilte Kompetenz in den
Bevölkerungsschutz sowie ist das
Grundgesetz Bund und Länder sind beide
verantwortlich sie müssen ihre in ihre
Fähigkeiten bündeln auch um Kosten zu
teilen und zu verringern
und einem Beispiel Waldbrand können wir
beispielhaft zeigen wie gute Bevölkerung
wie gut Bevölkerungsschutz aussieht das
Szenario ist klar ein großer Brand der
von den Einsatzkräften der Feuerwehr
nicht in den Griff zu kriegen ist wir
definieren ein Schutzziel in diesem Fall
der Schutz von Menschen Umwelt-
anhand des schutzziels und des Szenarios
bewerten wir die vorhandenen Fähigkeiten
wir sehen schnell dass wir
Schwachstellen haben zum Beispiel bei
Hubschraubern und Löschfahrzeugen aber
auch bei Vorsorge und Früherkennung mit
Drohnen und Länder ergänzen ihre
Ausstattung im gegenseitigen
Einvernehmen und die Menge schnell um
die Menge schnellstmöglich zu beenden zu
beheben soweit Mängel auch bei den
Zuständigkeit des meldewegen eine andere
Strukturen besteht werden auch diese
behoben werden am Ende steht der gute
Bevölkerungsschutz für das Szenario weit
waren sehr geehrte Damen und Herren die
ampelkonditionen Bevölkerungsschutz
gemeinsam mit den willigen Bundesländern
wir haben die Zeiten werden in
Bevölkerungsschutz eingeleitet und
werden sie konsequent verwirklichen wir
übernehmen politische Verantwortung und
werden die Erwartungen der Menschen
gerecht vielen Dank
soweit die Verteidigung hier von Ingo
Schäfer er sitzt wie auch der nächste
Redner im Ausschuss für Inneres und
Heimat und der nächste Steffen Jannik
für die afd-fraktion
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren das Jahr 2022 hat uns Deutschen
schmerzhaft die Gefahr durch Waldbrände
vor Augen geführt im Harz in Brandenburg
sowie in meiner Heimat der Sächsischen
Schweiz kam es zu wochenlang im Renten
welche riesige Waldflächen
buchstäblichen Asche legten wir und ich
hoffe ich kann da im Namen aller
Abgeordneten in diesem Haus sprechen
danken allen Helfern für den Fleiß ihren
Mut und ihre unterschiedlichen
Opferbereitschaft im Kampf gegen die
Flammen
und es ist deswegen erforderlich dass
wir die Themen Brandbekämpfung und
präventiven waldbrandschutz in den
Mittelpunkt drücken die
Kompetenzverteilung des Grundgesetzes
sieht jedoch für die allgemeine
Gefahrenabwehr grundsätzlich eine
Zuständigkeit der Länder vor hierzu
zählt auch der Brandschutz eine
ergänzende Ausstattung des Bundes im
Bereich des Brandschutzes kann den
Katastrophen Katastrophenschutz der
Länder nur ergänzen aber nicht ersetzen
die eine Nutzung der bundeseigenen
Fahrzeuge und Geräte im Bereich der
allgemeinen Gefahr Gefahrenabwehr also
unterhalb der Schwelle zur Katastrophe
sie das Gesetz bisher nicht vor sondern
wird vom Bund lediglich geduldet solange
sich an den
Zuständigkeitsverteilung zwischen
Katastrophenschutz und Zivilschutz im
Zusammenspiel mit den Ländern nichts
ändert ist es völlig unzweckmäßig den
Bund zum Hauptprotagonisten der
Waldbrandbekämpfung zu kümmern der
Antrag der CDU tut aber genau das ein
moderner Bevölkerungsschutz darf den
Katastrophenschutz und den Zivilschutz
nicht länger trennen beides ist eine
Einheit und die Parlamente müssen
hierfür die Grundlage schaffen
im Wortlaut ihres Antrages fordern sie
von der CDU die Bundesregierung auf das
Mindestmaß für vorsätzliche
Brandstiftung auf zwei Jahre zu erhöhen
die Strafbarkeit der Brandstiftung
ergibt sich jedoch aus dem
Strafgesetzbuch allein also einem
parlamentsgesetz des Bundes die CDU ist
in nunmehr 70 Jahren hier im Bundestag
vertreten offenbar müssen wir ihn von
der AFD noch erklären dass formelle
Gesetze grundgesetzkonform nur vom
Bundestag selbst und nicht von der
Regierung geändert werden können wenn es
ihnen mit der Forderung ernst ist denken
Sie doch bitte einen Gesetzesentwurf vor
zu
dem zu dem Antrag der Linken bleibt
festzustellen dass er ähnlich dem Antrag
von der CDU-Fraktion völlig außer Acht
lässt dass die Länder offene
Arbeitsgruppe nationaler waldbrandschutz
bereits verschiedene Konzepte zur
Brandbekämpfung erörtert hat die
fachlich zuständigen Experten haben sich
entgegen ihrer antragsforderung
einhelligt gegen den Einsatz von
Löschflugzeugen ausgesprochen dieser
Erkenntnis finden Sie nur auch nunmehr
im parlamentischen Dokumentationen
dokumentations- und Informationssystem
wenn sie mit der gebotenen Sorgfalt zu
diesem Thema recherchieren diesen
Umstand können auch Sie nicht einfach
ignorieren aber im Innenausschuss können
sie ja oder haben Sie die Möglichkeit
ihre Fehler im Änderungsantrag
auszubessern in dieser Form sind beide
Anträge leider nicht zustimmungsfähig
aber eine Sache
aber eine Sache kann der Bund heute
schon tun meine Anfrage zu dieser
Thematik hat ergeben dass der Bund den
Ländern im Rahmen der ergänzenden
Ausstattung für den Katastrophenschutz
in den letzten 15 Jahren 592
Löschgruppenfahrzeug und 135
Schlauchwagen bereitgestellt hat der
Stadtstaat Hamburg hat vom Bund mehr
katastrophenschutzfahrzeuge erhalten als
die waldreichen Flächenländer
Brandenburg Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und
Sachsen-Anhalt zusammen ich werde
hierfür dass der ergänzenden Ausstattung
des Bundes künftig die verwandtene
Waldfläche der Empfängerländer Stärke
Berücksichtigung findet das würde der
Verteilungsgerechtigkeit beim
Katastrophenschutz wesentlich mehr
entsprechen vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
und verbindest 90 die Grünen hat das
Wort Niklas wahrgenommen
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Folgen der
Klimakrise für den Wald sind auch in
diesem Jahr durch zahlreiche Waldbrände
wieder sehr deutlich geworden eine
Fläche von 660.000 Hektar weit ist in
Europa in diesem Sommer verbrannt auch
in Deutschland musste eine nie
dagewesene Waldfläche dem Feuer weichen
zunächst möchte ich einen Einsatzkräften
von der Feuerwehr über Polizei und
Bundeswehr bis hin zu unseren
försterinnen und Förstern sehr für ihren
engagierten Einsatz auch in diesem
Sommer dank
erst
erst vergangene Woche war ich gemeinsam
mit meinem Kollegen Eckert
im Grunewald gemeinsam mit dem Berliner
Landeskommando der Bundeswehr der
Landespolizei in Berliner Forsten haben
wir uns über die Schäden des Waldbrandes
informiert und auch über Lehren aus
diesem Brand Ereignis gesprochen während
die genaue Brandursache auf dem
Sprengplatz im Grunewald noch von einer
fachgutachterin ermittelt wird steht sie
in zahlreichen anderen Fällen längst
fest Brandstiftungen eine unachtsame
Zigarette oder das im Wald geparkte Auto
mit heißem Motor so banal es klingt aber
der beste Schutz gegen Waldbrände bleibt
Achtsamkeit im Wald und das Bewusstsein
in den Köpfen der Menschen das auf der
kleinste Funke ausreicht um einen
Flächenbrand zu verursachen
als ich kürzlich als ich kürzlich mit
dem renommierten Freiburger
feuerökologen Professor Goldammer
zusammensaß appellierte er noch mal an
mich dass wir 90 Prozent unserer
Anstrengungen in die Prävention
investieren müssen auch wenn der
durchaus richtige Ruf nach mehr
löschhubschraubern und Löschflugzeugen
auf den mein Kollege Eckert gleich noch
mal eingehen wird politisch greifbarer
und verlockender erscheint dürfen wir
nicht vergessen wo der eigentliche
Schwerpunkt unserer Politik liegen muss
in der Bekämpfung der Brandursachen als
Ampelkoalition stellen wir 900 Millionen
Euro für Klima angepasstes
weidmanagement zur Verfügung wer sein
weil so bewirtschaftet dass der
Waldumbau hin zu mehr Standort
heimischen Laubbäumen vorangetrieben
wird das entwässerungsstrukturen
zurückgebaut werden das Artenvielfalt im
Wald vorangetrieben wird erhält eine
Bundesförderung denn es sind die Kiefern
Reinbestände die besonders gut brennen
die Natur näher und artenreicher ein
waldbewir belastet wird umso besser ist
er für die Herausforderungen der
Klimakrise gewappnet wir müssen also
alle Anstrengungen investieren um den
Waldumbau in Deutschland zügig
voranzutreiben und dadurch aktive
waldbrandprävention zu betreiben
der beste waldbrandschutz bleibt am Ende
des Tages der Klimaschutz der nur auf
Hubschrauber setzt hat die Ursache nicht
verstanden wir tun also das eine ohne
das andere zu lassen herzlichen Dank
soweit in niklasse Wagner noch Student
der
Forstwirtschaft hier im Plenum und als
nächstes spricht für die Linksfraktion
André Hahn die Linksfraktion hat hier
auch einen Antrag eingereicht
fordert in ihrem Antrag durchaus viel
Richtiges das meiste ist also aus Sicht
der Linken im Prinzip unterstützenswert
und wir sollten darüber in der gebotenen
Gründlichkeit in den zuständigen
Fachausschüssen diskutieren was das
Löschen von Bränden aus der Luft angeht
bleibt der Antrag aber leider viel zu
taghaft sie beantragen lediglich das
Bund und Länder die Beschaffung von
löschhubschraubern und Flugzeugen prüfen
sollen auch auf der EU-Ebene sprechen
Sie beim rescu-mechanismus von aktiver
Unterstützung ohne wirklich konkreter zu
werden das klingt für mich wenig
ambitioniert und setzt eigentlich nur
den Kurs fort der unionsgeführten
Innenministerium im zivilen
bevölkerungs- und Katastrophenschutz der
letzten Jahre bedauerlicherweise
Standard gewesen ist
als Abgeordneter aus der Sächsischen
Schweiz bin ich davon überzeugt die
Folgen solcher Zaghaftigkeit werden
Menschen schlimmstenfalls schon in der
nächsten Waldbrandsaison ausbaden müssen
deshalb müssen wir jetzt gegensteuern
dazu gehört auch die jahrelange
Diskussion über die Anschaffung von
Löschflugzeugen möglichst schnell zu
beenden und endlich Nägel mit Köpfen zu
machen also die für die Brandbekämpfung
erforderliche Technik vorzuhalten
denn der Bedarf ist zweifelsfrei da und
die Einsatzszenarien sind es auch in der
Sächsischen Schweiz wie auch am Brocken
und ich mag mir gar nicht ausmalen in
welchem Gebieten in Deutschland
vielleicht schon in naher Zukunft meine
Damen und Herren wir dürfen nicht
abwarten bis wir allein hier in
Deutschland mehr waldbrandeinsätze haben
als die vorhandenen EU weiten
Kapazitäten abdecken können der Betrieb
der löschflugzeug-
und da orientiert es denn schon das SPD
und Grüne sich laut Presseberichten
dieser Tage für eine aus eu-bundes und
Landesmitteln finanzierte
niedersächsische Einheit von
Löschflugzeugen einsetzen wollen wir
brauchen aber keine regionalen
Alleingänge sondern eine bundesweite
Lösung und ich hätte im übrigen einige
Ideen wo diese flugzeugstaffel auch in
Ostdeutschland einen geeigneten Standort
finden könnte
wenn Bundeskanzler Scholz im Rahmen der
sogenannten zeitenwände im militärischen
Bereich ein 100 Milliarden
aufrüstungspaket verkündet dann stellt
sich die Frage warum nicht auch im
Bereich des zivilen Katastrophenschutzes
eine halbwegs vergleichbares Engagement
gezeigt wird den bundesweit waren nun
ablaufenden Jahr wieder häufig die
überwiegend ehrenamtlichen
Feuerwehreinheiten gefordert ich will
auch für meine Fraktion an dieser Stelle
den Einsatzkräften für ihr
herausragendes Engagement noch einmal
ganz herzlich danken
aber wir als Parlament müssen dann auch
die dringend dafür Sorge tragen dass
ihnen auch wirksame und effektive
Einsatzmittel zur Verfügung stehen die
LINKE fordert deshalb in einem eigenen
Antrag die Bundesregierung dazu auf eine
brandbekämpfungseinheit aufzustellen die
bei Waldbränden in Deutschland und in
Europa zum Einsatz gebracht werden kann
dazu gehören unabdingbar auch
Löschflugzeugen haben Sie bitte zum
Schluss Frau Präsidenten die dann sowohl
national als auch bei Bedarf am
europäischen Bereich eingesetzt werden
diskutiert haben wir lange genug jetzt
gilt es zu handeln
jetzt geht es zu handeln sagt André Hahn
das hat übrigens auch Sachsen-Anhalt
mitbekommen 2022 hat es dort deutlich
häufiger gebrannt als im Vorjahr und
deswegen wird auch der Forstminister
sachsen-anhaltsgleich sprechen wenn
Schulze nun erst einmal aber Sandra
bubendorfer Licht für die FDP-Fraktion
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
ich habe in der Antrag aufmerksam
gelesen und ich muss sagen ich stimme
Ihnen in den meisten Punkten inhaltlich
auch zu aber dann komme ich zu dem Punkt
wo ich mich doch Frage wieso haben wir
in Deutschland nicht schon längst eine
umfassende
waldbrandprävention deshalb haben wir im
Jahr 2022 noch kein umfassendes
Monitoring in Sachen Waldbrände das nun
endlich auch im Rahmen der
residenzstrategie der
fortschrittkoalition aufgebaut wird
warum berichten mir bayerische Fall
eines flächendeckenden Waldbrandes
lieber nicht da weil man da so schlecht
aufgestellt sei sie hatten 16 Jahre lang
die Verantwortung im
Bundesinnenministerium ebenso in den
Ländern bereits im Jahre
2018 als wir einen der heißesten Sommer
seit Wetteraufzeichnung hatten haben wir
auf die Problematik und enorme Gefahr
von Waldbränden unduriperioden
hingewiesen als Antwort kamen dünne bis
keine Auskünfte nicht vorhandene Daten
und große Fragezeichen
loben erwähnen möchte ich jedoch ihre
Forderungen nach Drohnen und digitalen
Präventionsmaßnahmen der rennen Sie bei
uns offene Türen ein
und genau das gehen wir jetzt an das
alles hätten wir aber auch gerne schon
früher initiiert unauf dem Weg gebracht
gesehen deshalb war es richtig dass wir
uns als fortschrittskoalition dem
europäischen rescueprogramm noch stärker
verpflichtet haben aus diesem Programm
ruft nun das Bundesland Niedersachsen
zwei Löschflugzeuge also stehen
beschafft der Bund aktuell 44 neue
Hubschrauber für die Bundespolizei auch
dieser Sommer hat gezeigt Waldbrände und
Ihre Perioden werden aufgrund des
Klimawandels stetig zunehmen und wurde
deutlich vor Augen geführt wie viele
Regionen mittlerweile in Gefahr geraten
Waldbrandgebiet zu werden gut dass hier
die fortschrittskoalition unendlich
anpackt
im Rahmen der im Juli verabschiedeten
resilienzstrategie werden wir als Bund
unterstützend die Widerstandsfähigkeit
des Waldes bei der Bewirtschaftung und
den Umbau in den Blick nehmen
schadensdaten werden dabei
ebenenübergreifend und im Austausch mit
dem Wissenschaft aufbereitet ebenso
werden Erfahrungen und
bewältigungsmaßnahmen vergangene
Ereignisse ausgewertet und
Handlungsempfehlungen in Kooperation mit
der Forschung erstellt
wichtiger grundlegende Ansatz dabei die
implementieren einen Ressort und
ebenenübergreifende Gesamtblick um den
dynamischen Anforderungen auch gerecht
zu werden
die fortschrittskoalition wirkt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir werden die
Kompetenzen und Kapazitäten des
Bundesamtes für Bevölkerungsschutz und
Katastrophenhilfe auch bei Waldbränden
kontinuierliche ausbauen wir werden das
360 Grad Lagebild im gemeinsamen melde
und Lagezentrum weiter ausbauen wir
werden den engen Austausch mit den
Ländern und den lagebildzentren vor Ort
ebenfalls investiert intensivieren sie
sehen wir packen an und das war auch in
Ihrem Sinne
lassen Sie mich Ihnen noch einen
Gedanken mitgeben sie legen in ihrem
Antrag den Fokus abschließend auf die
Erhöhung der Strafen bei fortsetzlicher
Brandstiftung bin ich vollkommen bei
ihnen aber ich bin der Ansicht dass wir
dort zunächst noch einmal die Menschen
dafür sensibilisieren müssen dass der
Faktor Mensch eben ein enorm großes
Gefahrenpotenzial bei Waldbränden
darstellt wir müssen doch den Fokus auf
Prävention und Vermeidung legen statt
auf Bestrafung nachdem ein Waldbrand
Natur Tier und Mensch gefährdet hat
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
packen wir gemeinsam im Bund in den
Ländern und den Kommunen an zum wohne in
unserer wunderbaren Landschaft unserer
Natur unter aller Sicherheit und ich
freue mich über die konstruktive
Unterstützung um Begleitung seitens der
Union gemeinsam packen würde es
herzlichen Dank
so und jetzt von der Regierungsbank
haben wir auch ein Sprecher wie schon
angekündigt der Forstminister
Sachsen-Anhalt Sven Schulze hat jetzt
das Wort um hier noch mal
auseinandersicht die Situation zu
beschreiben
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrter
Abgeordnete sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren ich freue mich heute hier auch
als Vertreter der Länder sprechen zu
dürfen denn es ist schon ein Thema was
uns in den Ländern sehr ja auch
beschäftigt wir hatten im Harz dass
meine Heimat wo ich herkomme in diesem
Jahr zwei große Waldbrände und gerade
bei dem letzten war ich tagtäglich vor
Ort mit der Kollegin Heike Bremer der an
Wahlkreises dort ist und wir haben
einmal mehr gesehen mit wichtiges Thema
das ist deswegen vielen Dank dass Sie
heute darüber diskutieren wenn man sieht
dass wir allein in Sachsen-Anhalt in den
letzten drei Jahren über 500 Waldbrände
hatten nicht jeder dieser Waldbrände ist
in den Medien zu sehen aber trotzdem
zeigt es wie wichtig es ist auf dieses
Thema hinzuweisen Sachsen und
Brandenburg hat eine ähnliche Erfahrung
machen müssen also ein Thema für ganz
Deutschland wie wollen wir den Wald
zukünftig besser schützen
Zuständigkeiten wurden schon benannt
waldbrandpräventionsmaßnahmen
Zuständigkeit die Waldbesitzer die
privaten als auch der Staat und da ist
es umso wichtiger dass wir da gemeinsam
eng zusammenarbeiten im Harz machen wir
das ganz intensiv gerade der
Nationalpark mit mir als Land mit den
Bürgermeister der Stadt Wernigerode mit
dem Landrat parteiübergreifend arbeiten
wir da intensiv zusammen das zeigt auch
geht sich darum aufeinander
einzuschlagen sondern geht es darum
einfach zu schauen wie können wir die
besten Lösungen suchen Waldbrand
Waldbrand Bekämpfung
Zuständigkeit Länder und Kommunen das
ist grundsätzlich richtig aber ich
möchte auch mal als zuständiger Minister
den Bund loben ganz explizit den Bund
für den Katastrophenschutz wir haben
Bundeswehr und Bundespolizei mit vor Ort
gehabt übrigens vermutlich dass die
Hubschrauber nicht in den letzten
Monaten angeschafft worden sondern
irgendwann in den letzten 16 Jahren wenn
ihr immer gesagt wird es wurde nur
gespart
und ich habe schon vernommen und das
wundert mich schon ein bisschen dass man
jetzt über Kürzungen im Haushalt für
zivil und Katastrophenschutz diskutiert
schauen sich an was im Harz los war dann
sollte auf keinen Fall gekürzt werden
ich möchte auch
das sage ich mal als als ehemaliger
Abgeordneter des Europäischen Parlaments
die eu-staffel loben wir hatten
italienische Flugzeuge bei uns ohne
diese Flugzeuge hätten wir den Brand
nicht bekämpfen können und unsere
trauriger ist es das eines dieser
Flugzeuge weniger Wochen später
abgestürzt ist die Mannschaft ums Leben
gekommen ist das hat uns sehr bedrückt
und deswegen gilt noch mal mein Dank
allen Kameradinnen und Kameraden die uns
in den letzten Jahren in ganz
Deutschland geholfen haben egal ob es
Feuerwehr war obs THW war die haben
vieles geleistet
ich komme aber auch als Ländervertreter
nicht ohne Forderungen können sich
vorstellen
wir müssen das Thema Kosten auch mal
diskutieren der letzte Brand im Harz hat
die hat den Landkreis eine Million Euro
pro Tag gekostet das überfordert einen
Landkreises überfordert jede Kommune das
überfordert irgendwann auch Länder und
ich will auch nicht dass man aus dem
Bundeshaushalt Gelder zur Verfügung
stellt aber ich will zumindest mal
anregen auch Richtung Bundesregierung
über einen nationalen Waldbrand vom zu
diskutieren wo wir Gelder einstellen
könnten die dann in solchen Fällen auch
zur Verfügung stehen das ist ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt wir werden in den
nächsten Jahren glaube ich da auch große
Herausforderung auf der Kostenseite
haben das muss weiter diskutiert werden
und ich finde es richtig und gut
Minister erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage
des
Kollegen aus der FDP-Fraktion
nein ihre Redepause wird angehalten
zwei Minuten sogar zur Antwort
ich bitte kurz mal um Ruhe so dass wir
jetzt die Frage hören können so ja
vielen Dank dass Sie die Zwischenfrage
zulassen sie haben jetzt so ein bisschen
angefangen Forderungen Richtung Bund zu
zu berichten Frage an Sie wie weit sind
Sie Ihren präventionsbestrebungen wie
viel Wasservorräte haben sie in der
Fläche das ist nämlich das Hauptproblem
dass diese ganzen reservas nicht da sind
und ich glaube daran müssen wir arbeiten
und das ist eindeutig länderaufgabe
zweite Teilfrage an sie sie haben sehr
viel Totholz auch im Wald rumstehen das
ist eine riesen Brandlast wie gehen Sie
damit um
tja da muss ich
Ihnen sagen es wäre schön gewesen wenn
Sie noch eine Minute gewartet hätten
hätte ich genau das Thema Totholz auch
eingegangen und
und auch und auch zu dem zu dem
wasserreservas das ist genau ein Punkt
den wir auch im Nationalpark Harz haben
ich darf jetzt zwei Minuten Antworten
das müssen
wir haben im Nationalpark Harz das ist
der einzige Nationalpark
länderübergreifend
Sachsen-Anhalt Niedersachsen in
gemeinschaftliches Projekt auch wenn man
den Brocken sieht das ist ja dieses
Symbol schlechthin für die deutsche
Teilung mit gewesen bei uns in der
Region und wir haben es über Jahre
hinweg im Nationalpark nicht hinbekommen
entsprechend Wasser zur Verfügung zu
stellen lag möglicherweise auch in der
zuständige Ministerin in Sachsen-Anhalt
Kollegin Frau dalbert von den Grünen war
da nicht immer die kooperativste das
muss man auch mal ehrlicherweise sagen
auch wenn es nicht jedem gefallen wird
das ist ein riesen Thema Punkt sie haben
so recht angesprochen das ist unsere
Aufgabe müssen wir umsetzen machen wir
auch bei uns in Sachsen-Anhalt und das
Thema Totholz gehe ich gleich noch sehr
intensiv aber auch kurz und knapp ein
ich möchte noch mal Einsatz sagen
selbstverständlich zwei Minuten habe ich
noch ich habe gehört Reste eu-staffel
habe ich auch schon gesagt und ich freue
mich ganz ehrlich dass jetzt endlich
auch Deutschland sich beteiligen wird
aber ein Stück weit weg vom Jubel ich
habe das als eu-hauptmann die war mit
dabei auch erlebt wie ist denn war vor
einigen Jahren als Deutschland schon mal
hätte sich beteiligen können da hat man
in Brüssel gesagt das ist in deutschen
zu teuer und damals in der letzten
Legislatur weiß man auch wenn die
Verantwortung für Finanzen ja also bitte
einfach darum nicht immer zu sagen jetzt
funktioniert es damals nicht
funktioniert sollte man immer auch
Bedenken deshalb absolut
unterstützenswert das Thema Totholz
wir werden beispielsweise den gesamten
Nationalpark herzlich von Totholz
befreien können will niemand machen aber
es geht um ein ganz wichtiges Thema
Gebietsschutz das heißt an einzelnen
Stellen Totholz zu entnehmen
beispielsweise im Wohnbebauung zu
schützen um Brandschneisen zu schlagen
damit die Feuerwehrleute besser anbrannt
Herde kommen den Nationalpark Harz
entsprechend besser vorzubereiten falls
es wieder brennt genau das haben wir
jetzt gemacht insgesamt wenn es mal
hochrechnen 0,1% des Nationalparks will
ich von Totholz befreien auf dem Gebiet
von Sachsen-Anhalt und was passiert es
gibt einen Umweltverband der gerade
gegen klagt und sagt das darf so nicht
seine Sachen ganz ehrlich auch in
Richtung Umweltverbände das versteht von
den Menschen dort niemand mehr und das
hilft uns am Ende in der Debatte nicht
ich möchte einen ganz wichtiges Thema
war noch ansprechen
das erlaube ich mir jetzt auch frau
Präsidentin ich bin zwar hier für den
Bundesrat ich bin aber gleichzeitig auch
Vorsitzender der Agrarministerkonferenz
der Länder zumindest noch bis Ende
diesen Jahres und hier ist einfach die
Aufforderung ich habe als
agrarministerkonferenzvorsitzender eine
eigene Agrarministerkonferenz zum Thema
Wald ins Leben berufen und haben wir
viele dieser Themen diskutiert und wir
haben im September auf der
Agrarministerkonferenz von Cem Özdemir
gehört er wäre zukünftig bereit einmal
im Monat mit uns agrammen
ist mittlerweile Ende November wir haben
uns noch nicht getroffen das heißt wenn
man uns zusagt einmal im Monat
miteinander zu reden auch zu solchen
Themen sollte man das auch einhalten wir
brauchen als Länder hier eine bessere
Diskussionskultur mit der
Bundesregierung das funktioniert noch
nicht vielen Dank für die Möglichkeit
ich habe meine Redezeit eingehalten
herzlichen Dank
der Forstminister Sachsen-Anhalt Sven
Schulze geht jetzt natürlich nicht
zurück zur Regierungsbank sondern zur
bundesratsbank hat ihr hier gesprochen
es ist ihm ein Anliegen nach Angaben des
landeszentrums gab es 80 Waldbrände in
Sachsen-Anhalt im ersten Halbjahr 2022
bereits sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrter
Herr Schulze die nationale
Kraftanstrengung für einen besseren
waldbrandschutzes eine sehr wichtiges
Thema und gerade in meiner Region in
Niedersachsen denn der Harz hat in den
in diesem Jahr ein langanhaltenden
Waldbrand in dem Brocken erfahren im
Nationalpark im Nachbarbundesland
Sachsen-Anhalt das ist eines meiner
beliebtesten Laufstrecken die ich im
Harz gerne Durchführung glauben Sie mir
ich habe diese enorme Schäden auch immer
noch vor Augen wenn ich 45 km entfernt
aus meinem Wohnzimmer fährt Fenster
Richtung südenschauer waren die auch
sparen deutlich zu erkennen das
bedrückte schon sehr gerade die jungen
nachwachsenden Pflanzen zwischen den
abgestorbenen Bäumen die schon durch
rotwildverbiss gefährdet waren fiel nun
den Flammen zum Opfer das ist sehr
beklemmend Frau Wittmann in diesem Jahr
vieles in niedersächsischen Landesforst
und dem Auswahlkomitee schwer einen
geeigneten Weihnachtsbaum für den
Bundestag zu finden im Harz gibt es
nämlich nicht mehr die geeigneten
Fichten 25 Meter hoch ungefähr 60 Jahre
alt das ist in Borkenkäfer der
Trockenheit und der Stürme haben da
ihren Tribut gezeugt nun wurde sie aber
gefunden die Tanne aus dem Altenauer
kellerwasser und kann wie jedes Jahr vor
dem Westportal das Reichstagsgebäude
behindert werden und ich hoffe und ich
glaube auch meine Kolleginnen liebe
Frauke Heiligenstadt das ist auch im
nächsten Jahr möglich der Waldbrand im
Harz war nicht der einzige dieses Jahr
verehrte Damen und Herren auch im
Landkreis Gifhorn Gifhorn St einige
große Flächen Unterholz in Flammen und
erinnerten die Bürgerinnen und Bürger an
den heidebrand in den 70er Jahren und es
brannte in Brandenburg und in der
Sächsischen Schweiz das wurde hier schon
genannt und in vielen anderen Bereichen
auch und das verdeutlicht dass wir nicht
nur die Folgeschäden sondern auch die
Auslöser und die Ursache von Waldbrand
effektiv bekämpfen müssen nämlich den
Klimawandel und an dieser Stelle muss
ich Ihnen sagen dass Sie meine Damen und
Herren von der Union bei der
ursprungsbekämpfung in den letzten
Jahren leider nicht viel bewegt haben
denn waldbrandschutz beginnt nicht erst
wenn die Krise eingetreten ist die
Vorbereitung Bewältigung und
Nachbereitung muss gleichrangig in den
Blick genommen werden Länder
übergreifend ich kann Ihnen aber
versichern dass wir andere Prioritäten
setzen in unserem Koalitionsvertrag
haben wir festgeschrieben dass wir
bundesweite präventionsbekämpfung
Strategien erarbeiten und die
waldbrandbekämpfungsmöglichkeiten am
Boden und in der Luft ausbauen weiter
Menschen werden dir eine bodenschonende
weitbearbeitung fördern wie zum Beispiel
mit dem 900 Millionen Euro durch das
Förderprogramm Klima angepasst des
weidmanagement mein Kollege Wagner hat
das gerade erwähnt klar ist dass wir
unser Land krisenfester machen müssen
und das machen wir indem wir insgesamt
etwa
639 Millionen Euro im Haushalt
2023 für Katastrophen zivile
Bevölkerungsschutz zur Verfügung stellen
über 36 Millionen investieren in die
Warnung von Bevölkerung außer durch den
stellen wir als Bund für die Beschaffung
weiterer Löschfahrzeuge für den
Katastrophen Katastrophenschutz in den
Ländern zusätzlich 5 Millionen Euro ein
wir haben nicht gespart die nationale
Strategie zur Waldbrandbekämpfung muss
die Folgen des Klimawandels abwehren wir
müssen die nötige Technik einsetzen das
kann eben aus der Luft erfolgen oder mit
künstlicher Intelligenz ich selbst haben
wir die Brandbekämpfung vor Ort
angesehen und wir sind sehr dankbar für
die Italien der flugunterstützung die
zeigt dass wir in Europa gut
zusammenarbeiten und vernetzt sind auf
innenministerseite und auf kommunaler
Seite die beiden Landräte aus Goslar aus
dem Landkreis harzstein Schulter an
Schulter und auch der niedersächsische
Innenminister mit Ihnen zusammen Herr
Schulze waren schnell vor Ort um die
Herausforderung anzugehen aber sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren es gibt ihnen
nicht den nachhaltigkeitsbaum Mischwald
das muss unser Konzept sein nicht zu
viele vertikale Schneisen im Wald ziehen
wiedervermessung und Biodiversität
das ist unser Weg und ich bitte keine
aufgeräumten Wälder dennoch müssen die
nötigen Sicherheitszonen im Brandfall
geschaffen werden Konzepte sind wie
gerade eben erfahrenen Arbeit Totholz
findet Feuchtigkeit und liefert Substrat
für den aufwuchs schützt den Boden vor
Sonneneinstrahlung und hält vor allen
Dingen die Insekten am Leben und
Nebenfluss Insekten sind insbesondere
der große Verlust am Boden Insekten
einen größeren Probleme Monokultur muss
der Vergangenheit haben gehören
nachhaltiger Waldbau und
umweltschonender Tourismus nimmt die
Bevölkerung mit zum Ende möchte ich kurz
von meiner Mutter sprechen die in ihren
jungen Jahren Krieg Flucht und
Verfolgung erlebt hat und im Landkreis
Wolfenbüttel in Dettum ihre Heimat
gefunden hat für alle Menschen die ihre
Heimat bei uns gefunden haben ist neben
dem nachhaltigen Umgang mit unserer
Umwelt vor allem Respekt Akzeptanz und
dass wir kommen sein wichtig frau
Präsidentin ich komme zum letzten Satz
das neue
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht ist der
entscheidende Schritt dahin und hilft
nicht nur bei der fragebindung sondern
auch bei der Stärkung des Ehrenamtes dem
es an Nachwuchs fehlt und meiner Mutter
kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss jetzt alles
liebe zum 85 geburtstag
ja hier gab es noch mal Glückwünsche zum
Geburtstag und damit kommen wir zum
letzten Redner in dieser Debatte das ist
Leon Eckert für Bündnis 90 die Grünen im
Deutschen Bundestag sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Kolleginnen
Kollegen liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Deutschland ist Waldbrand das zeigt die
die letzte Waldbrandsaison wir sind
mitten im Klima in der Klimakrise
angekommen und ich glaube wir sind uns
einig mit den Antragstellern über die
zentrale Bedeutung unserer Wälder
alle Vorredner haben es auch gesagt
deswegen werde ich da sind viele gute
Sachen drin im Antrag auf die Punkte
eingehen ich glaube in wo wir in die
Diskussion gehen müssen um auch den
besten Weg zu finden das ist einmal die
Zuständigkeitsfrage Katastrophenschutz
Zivilschutz wir haben schon gesagt in
einem der Zivilschutz
Konzeption gehört kein Waldbrand weil
der Zivilschutz ist da wenn wir
angegriffen werden wenn Raketen fliegen
wenn wir unsere Bevölkerung schützen
müssen
Wälder sind da nachrangige Schutzziele
in so einer Ausnahmesituation deswegen
gehören in zivilschutzausrüstung
eigentlich keine vegetationsbrand das
muss man sich bewusst werden wenn man
Zivilschutz fordert dann wird man kein
vegetationskranken bekommen das ist
Katastrophenschutz und
Katastrophenschutz ist reine Ländersache
und das sieht man auch im Antrag man
verwischt immer mal wieder die Spuren
was ist Zivilschutz was ist
Katastrophenschutz weil wir alle was
machen wollen und dann kommen wir eben
immer mal wieder in so ein Bereich und
das sehen wir eben am geh-kopf die Kopf
sind die Länder freiwillig versammelt
und sich abzustimmen um sich zu
koordinieren
waldbrandkoordination man hat jetzt ein
einheitliches Einsatz Kontingent für
vegetationsband gebildet die Länder
Niedersachsen NRW Bayern drei von 16 ist
das unser Anspruch das drei von 16 das
ist was aus der Zusammenarbeit von Bund
und Ländern entsteht ich glaube nicht
und Sachsen-Anhalt ist leider aber da
kann ich das gleich als Appell mitgeben
ja noch nicht mal ständig vertreten im
g-kopf das wäre so eine bitte ich glaube
das geht Kopf wird dann stark wenn alle
16 Bundesländer auch dauerhaft da sind
und dann auch diese Energie zu
aktivieren wenn der Katastrophe ist
schnell Einheiten zu verlegen schnell
Nachforderungen zu geben und dann auch
solche Konzepte zu harmonisieren von den
einsatzkontingenten bis zur
dachkennzeichnung nur NRW hat eine
Regelung für dachkennzeichnung für
vegetationsbandeinheiten das wäre doch
ein Projekt wo man sich mal unter den 16
Bundesländern einig werden könnte machen
wir doch gemeinsam damit nicht jedes
Fahrzeug aus jedem Bundesland anders
gekennzeichnet ist
zweiter Punkt Löschflugzeuge
Löschflugzeuge helfen in manchen
Extremsituationen flächig hier Brände
sicher aber die sind nicht der
Heilsbringer die sind ein kleiner
Baustein ein Waldbrand ein
vegetationsband wird am Boden
entschieden mit unseren Bodentruppen und
das müssen die Kommunen und die Länder
schaffen unsere Feuerwehren umzurüsten
andere PSA geländegängige Fahrzeuge wir
brauchen Übungen und Konzepte auf
Landkreisebene um in die Fläche zu
kommen da sind ganz viele Landkreise
dabei aber da müssen manche Länder auch
Hausaufgaben machen Förderung
bayerisches Tanklöschfahrzeug 60.000 für
eine halbe Million Fahrzeug das wird
sich kaum ein Landkreis leisten können
und der dritte Punkt verschärfe von
Strafen da bin ich skeptisch weil viele
Brände eben unabsichtlich passieren ich
glaube viel mehr dass wir in die
Prävention geben müssen viel breitere
Kampagnen die weggeschnittene Kippe das
unachtsam abgestellte Fahrzeug damit
verhindern können wir haben viel zu tun
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam angehen
sagt Leon Eckert und das wird auch
gemeinsam angegangen werden zumindest
was die Bearbeitung dieser Anträge
angeht die werden nämlich in den
Innenausschuss erst einmal überwiesen
und dort dann weiter diskutiert
wir blicken jetzt in der Debatte auf die
Ukraine allerdings geht es in nicht um
den aktuellen Krieg sondern um
holoumor das beschreibt die Hungersnot
in der Ukraine und da gibt es einen
Antrag der koalitionsfraktion SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen FDP und cdu/csu
die möchten nämlich dass diese
Hungersnot nun als
Menschheit zu Verbrechen anerkannt wird
und wir sehen hier auch dass der
aktuelle ukrainische Botschafter
olexijew dieser Debatte deswegen von der
Zuschauer Tribüne bei wohnt denn die
Ukraine bemüht sich schon seit 1991 sich
um eine internationale Anerkennung des
holodumors als Völkermord das ist
bislang noch umstritten einige Staaten
unter anderem der Vatikan haben sich der
Deutung der Ukraine bereits
angeschlossen Deutschland bisher noch
nicht aber das soll nun geändert werden
so fordern es eben die Fraktionen
Stadien hatte damals die
Zwangskollektivierung in der
Landwirtschaft befohlen und das führte
dazu dass es sehr viel Hunger in der
Ukraine gab
viel Getreide und Saatgut liest Stalin
damals in ukrainischen Dörfern
beschlagnahmen
hier gibt es jetzt Applaus auch für den
ukrainischen Botschafter
es ist eine große Ehre dass sie unserer
Debatte folgen und auch an den Klinik
ist da der stellvertretende
Außenminister der Ukraine herzlich
willkommen
für die Debatte sind 39 Minuten
Aussprache vorgesehen und als ersten
Redner erteile ich Robin Wagner das Wort
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Wagner eröffnet also die Debatte erst
der europapolitische Sprecher von
Bündnis 90 die Grünen im Deutschen
Bundestag
frau Präsidentin lieber Herrn
Botschafter liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
der hungertote eines Menschen verläuft
in den immer gleichen Phasen
in der ersten Phase verbraucht der
Körper seine glukosevorräte ein extremes
Hungergefühl setzt ein dazu ständige
Gedanken an Essen
in der zweiten Phase die mehrere Wochen
andauern kann beginnt der Körper sein
Fett zu verbrennen der Organismus wird
dramatisch geschwächt
in der dritten Phase verbraucht der
Körper sein eigenes Eiweiß Zert Gewebe
und Muskeln auf die Haut wird dünner die
Augen werden größer der Hals wirkt
länger Beine und bauchschwellen an
kleinste Bewegung erfordern große
Kraftanstrengung verschiedenste
Begleiterkrankungen beschleunigen den
Tod
Typhus Diphtherie
dies meine Damen und Herren ist keine
Theorie dies ist das Schicksal von
millionen-ukrainerinnen und Ukrainern
die 1932 1933 am mörderischen Hunger
gestorben sind das sind die Opfer derer
wir heute gedenken
es sind die Schilderungen die uns die
HistorikerInnen überliefern das sind die
Bilder die der aus dem heutigen leviv
stammende polnisch jüdische Jurist
Raphael Lemkin auch vor Augen hatte als
er den Begriff des Genozids des
Völkermords prägte Bilder von Kindern
die im Klassenzimmer sitzen
zusammenbrachen und verstarben
deren Körper anschwollen deren Haut
wegen massivster Unterernährung
durchsichtigt wurde deren hauteriss
Erzählung über Mütter die die Hoffnung
auf das Überleben ihrer Kinder verloren
die Söhne und Töchter präventiv töteten
damit diese den Hunger nicht länger
aushalten mussten
damit sie das wenige Brot nicht teilen
mussten
das ist der Horror der sich hinter dem
Begriff holodumor verbirgt dem Mord
durch Hunger
und dieser Horror hatte seine Ursache
nicht etwa in einer Naturgewalt nicht in
schicksalhaften Missernten auf dem
fruchtbaren Boden der Ukraine dieser
Horror hatte seine Ursache im Kreml dort
traf der Diktator die grausame
Entscheidung die Kollektivierung mit
Gewalt durchzudrücken und den Hunger zu
verursachen und die Tötung durch Hunger
hatte auch die politische Unterdrückung
des ukrainischen Nationalbewusstseins
der ukrainischen Kultur und Sprache zum
Ziel
meine Damen und Herren die Parallelen
zur heutigen Zeit sind unübersehbar
wieder versucht ein Diktator im Kreml
die Ukraine zu unterwerfen sie zu
vernichten heute nutzt Putin dafür nicht
allein die grausame Gewalt seiner
Söldner und Soldaten er nutzt nicht
allein den Terror von Drohnen und
Raketen er nutzt auch die gezielte
Geschichtsfälschung als
Handlungsgrundlage seines Krieges gegen
die Ukraine
schon in der Sowjetunion wurde der
holodomor-systematisch verleugnet und
tabuisiert
wir wissen heute dass die russischen
Besatzer das Mahnmal zum Gedenken an den
hungermord in mariopol zerstört haben
für die Verbrechen Stalins gibt es
keinen Platz in der ideologisierten
Geschichtspolitik Wladimir Putins
deswegen verbietet der Organisationen
wie zum Beispiel Memorial
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen gegen
diese Politik des Kremls hilft vor allem
Aufklärung und Bildung die Schrecken des
solodomors genau wie die deutschen
Verbrechen gegen die Sowjetunion und
viele andere Kapitel der wechselvollen
Geschichte der Ukraine und Osteuropas
gehören prominenter in die
Geschichtsbücher und Schulen denn
Wissenschaft nicht nur Empathie
Wissenschaft Widerstandsfähigkeit gegen
Propaganda und Geschichtsklitterung
mit unserem Antrag setzen wir uns mit
der brutalen Wahrheit stalinistischer
Gewalt auseinander nicht um die
deutschen Verbrechen in der Sowjetunion
zu relativieren sondern um aus der
historischen Wahrheit zu lernen
interfraktionell eint uns der Wunsch zu
erinnern zu gedenken zu mahnen und darum
mein Dank an alle Beteiligten in den
Fraktionen die diesen Antrag gemeinsam
getragen haben
und unser Mann muss auch den Blick auf
die Realität in der Ukraine heute
beinhalten am 280 Tag seit Russland vor
den Version wenn wir uns der Wahrheit
nicht verschließen wollen dann dürfen
wir die Augen vor den heutigen Opfern
nicht verschließen zu diesen Opfern
gehört sehr hier sehr hier wurde heute
vor genau einer Woche getötet durch
russische Raketen
solche wurde gerade von seiner Mutter
gestillt und zum Schlafen in die Wiege
gelegt kurz danach schlugen russische
Raketen in die Entbindungsklinik ein
series Mutter durchlebte neun Monate
einer Schwangerschaft in der Zeit des
Terrors des Krieges
sehr hier wurde vergangene Woche getötet
er wurde 48 Stunden alt
putinswunsch bleibt die vollständige
Unterwerfung der Ukraine und ihrer
Menschen russische Staatsziel ist die
Vernichtung der Ukraine als
eigenständiger Staat es macht mich nicht
zum Kriegstreiber belizisten oder
russenhasser wenn ich Kindern wie sehr
hier dein Leben und ein Überleben
ermöglichen möchte wenn ich mich dafür
einsetze dass wir unser starkes
Engagement für die Ukraine noch weiter
stärken
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn
wir es gemeinsam schaffen uns diesem
Vernichtungskrieg entgegenzustellen die
politische historische Einordnung des
solodomos als Völkermord ist darum nicht
nur Mahnungen sondern auch Auftrag an
uns alle das ist unsere Pflicht diesen
Wahnsinn zu stoppen und diesen Appell
richtig nicht nur an uns
Parlamentarierinnen und Parlamentarier
ich richte ihn an uns alle und damit
auch an die Russinnen und Russen in
Deutschland im Ausland in Russland
navigieren
stoppen Sie diesen Krieg
asternavidia Putina stoppen sie Putin
vielen Dank
fraktionsübergreifend gibt es hier
Applaus für Robin Wagner diese Antrag
wurde ja auch
fraktionsübergreifend eingereicht von
SPD den Grünen FDP und
cdu/csu Fraktion und für die
Unionsfraktion spricht nun Michael
Brandt der Sprecher für Menschenrechte
und humanitäre Hilfe
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Herr Botschafter meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren sie sollten
sterben weil sie Ukraine sind ein ganzes
Volk sollte sterben so hat es gestern
Abend in Berliner Dom bei einer
besonderen Gedenkveranstaltung der
ukrainische Bischof Bogdan Jurak
formuliert der Deutsche Bundestag wird
heute anerkennen dass die Ukraine von
der sowjetischen Führung in Moskau zum
Opfer eines Völkermords gemacht wurde
dabei wurden Millionen ermordet und
Hunger wurde zur tödlichen Waffe gemacht
es wurde systematisch selektiert um
Träger der ukrainischen Kultur
Wissenschaft und Geschichte zu verfolgen
zu ermorden ja es sollte das ukrainische
Volk vernichtet werden nichts weniger
spricht Bände historisch und politisch
dass der Massenmörder Stalin dessen
Denkmäler unter Gorbatschow von Jelzin
weniger wurden und verschwanden von
Vladimir Putin wieder zu einer Ikone
Russlands gemacht wurde es war kein
Zufall dass bei der Besetzung mariopols
durch die Truppen Putins das Denkmal für
die Opfer des holoumor gezielt und
propagandistisch vernichtet worden ist
wenn sich manche heute fragen warum wir
von der Brutalität und dem
Vernichtungswillen eines Putin
überrascht worden dann müssen sie sich
auch fragen warum sie die Zeichen an der
Wand nicht gesehen haben warum die
Restauration eines der größten
menschheitsverbrechers durch Putin sie
nicht viel früher aufgeschreckt hat und
für uns alle muss heute gelten was Lehre
der eigenen deutschen Geschichte ist nie
wieder darf weder in deutschen noch im
russischen Namen geschehen was durch den
holoumor und die Nazis an Massenmord in
der Ukraine begangen wurde
einer der renommiertesten Kenner der
Geschichte der Ukraine Timothy Snyder
hat darauf hingewiesen dass die
schlimmste Phase des Holocausts mit den
deutschen Massenmorden in der Ukraine
begann er hat auch darauf hingewiesen
dass in der gesamten so wertunion die
Ukraine und nicht Russland die
prozentual und auch nominal mit Abstand
höchste Zahl an Opfern durch den
deutschen Vernichtungskrieg zu beklagen
hat noch immer und das wollen wir heute
ein Stück verändern wird ausgerechnet in
Deutschland dieses enorme Leiden der
Ukrainer sowohl unter Stalin als dann
unter Nazi Deutschland nicht hinreichend
erinnert nicht genügend respektiert und
nicht in der deutschen Haltung gegenüber
der Ukraine berücksichtigt das liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen muss sich
ändern und zwar gründlich
so kommen wir heute dazu zwar später als
andere endlich den Völkermord an den
Ukrainern durch Moskau als einen solchen
auch anzuerkennen gerade wir Deutschen
stehen hier in einer besonderen
historischen Schuld und Verantwortung
gegenüber gegenüber der Ukraine und es
war nicht richtig dass unsere
Initiativen im Parlament schon früher
vor dem 90 jahres-tag auch mit Verweis
auf Russland nie mitgetragen wurden
es ist schlicht nicht fair gegenüber den
Opfern dieses Völkermords und ich sage
auch das ich hätte mir gewünscht dass
auch die erste Reihe des Bundeskabinetts
heute an dieser Debatte teilnimmt kein
einziger Bundesminister liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir verneigen
uns vor den Opfern für uns heißt nie
wieder heute wir dürfen nicht noch
einmal schuldig werden wenn wir der
Ukraine nicht endlich mit allem helfen
was wir tun können werden wir ein
zweites Mal schuldig Slava Ukraine
Michael Brandt ist natürlich auch wenn
das hier ein fraktionsübergreifender
Antrag ist weiterhin in der Opposition
und hat dementsprechend auch hier noch
mal die Bundesregierung kritisiert dass
hier kein Bundesminister der Debatte
beiwohnt Gabriela Heinrich spricht jetzt
für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrter Herr Botschafter sehr
geehrter Herr stellvertretende
Außenminister liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
es gibt Debatten bei denen Parteipolitik
und Abgrenzung voneinander schlichtweg
unangemessen sind und es gibt Anträge
die erst dann Gewicht entfalten wenn
eine breite Mehrheit des politischen
Spektrums dahinter steht ich bin deshalb
froh dass wir zum holodumor heute
gemeinsam agieren danke dafür vielen
herzlichen Dank
Dankeschön auch gerade deswegen weil wir
aus Deutschlands eigener Vergangenheit
eine besondere Verantwortung ableiten
innerhalb der internationalen
Gemeinschaft Menschenrechtsverbrechen
kenntlich zu machen und aufzuarbeiten
auch wenn es bei meinen Vorrednerinnen
auch schon Anklang ich glaube wir
sollten uns die Fakten noch mal vor
Augen führen die nackten Zahlen schon am
Ende der 1920er Jahre waren Lebensmittel
in der Sowjetunion knapp
hunderttausende verhungerten im Winter
1931 32 am 14 dezember 1932 unterschrieb
Stalin den Beschluss über die
getreidebeschaffung in der Ukraine im
Nordkaukasus und in der westregion
im darauffolgenden Winter verhungerten
in der Ukraine drei bis 3,5 Millionen
Menschen und das ist nur eine Schätzung
auch in Kasachstan waren es zwei
Millionen Menschen weitere
hunderttausende verhungerten in der
kubanregion und entlang der Flüsse Wolga
und Don
wie gesagt diese Zahlen sind Schätzungen
aber jede dieser Zahlen schildert das
Ausmaß der unvorstellbaren Verbrechen
gegen die Menschlichkeit hinter all
diesen Millionen stehen Menschen die
qualvoll an Unterernährung starben die
wenigen zeitgenössischen Berichte
beschreiben grausame Szenen verhungern
der Kinder mit aufgeblähten Bäuchen und
irgendwas noch mal deutlich zu machen es
waren geplant ungeheure Verbrechen
diese Katastrophe beruht nicht auf
missern die Ernte im gesamten Land wurde
kollektiviert und der Bevölkerung das
Essen einfach weggenommen
der Hunger wurde als Waffe und als
mittelstalinistischer Säuberungen
eingesetzt der Zentralstaat zielte damit
auch auf die Unterdrückung des
ukrainischen national Bewusstsein
Angehörige der ukrainischen Eliten
wurden verfolgt sie wurden inhaftiert
und sie wurden ermordet wenn sie nicht
schon verhungert war
von all dem betroffen war die gesamte
Ukraine nicht nur die Region die als
Kornkammer gelten
sehr verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Historiker Gerhard Simon bezeichnete
das Verschweigen als den letzten Akt
dieser Verbrechen ein halbes Jahrhundert
lang sei der holodumor zum Tabu zum
nicht geschehen geworden
nicht einmal in geheimen Dokumenten der
sowjetischen Führung sind die Hunger
Toten erwähnt
nur in den Familien und unter Freunden
sei das Wissen um das Grauen dieser
Jahre erhalten geblieben so Simon aus
politisches historischer Sicht heute ein
Völkermord
erst seit 1998 gibt es in der Ukraine
den offiziellen Tag der Erinnerung an
die Opfer des solodomore immer am 4
Samstag im November und dieser Tag ist
bedeutend
Traumata die nicht aufgearbeitet werden
belasten nicht nur die Überlebenden und
die Zeitzeugen mit all den Folgen die
wir heute aus der trauma-forschung
kennen vererben sie sich auch an die
nächsten Generationen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Hula
war eine gewollte und geplante
hungersnut um die Ukraine gefügig zu
machen um sie dem sowjetischen System
einzufahren die Ukraine hat das nicht
vergessen und doch wir werden es nicht
vergessen was passiert also jetzt
was passiert also jetzt wenn ein
Wladimir Putin sagt die Ukraine seien
unveräußerlicher Teil der russischen
Geschichte Kultur und Religion was
passiert jetzt bei der sinnlosen
Zerstörung der Infrastruktur was
passiert angesichts der vielen Opfer der
vielen Toten und Verwundeten was
passiert angesichts eines Krieges der
darauf angelegt ist die Ukraine zu
vernichten wieder zu vernichten
womit Putin nicht gerechnet hat
dass auch die Erinnerung an den
hulodomor die Ukrainerin und Ukrainer
zusammenschweißt der holotumor hat sich
tief im nationalen Gedächtnis der
Ukraine eingegraben und dass wir heute
gemeinsam diesen Antrag verabschieden
das herrschweist uns vielleicht auch
noch einmal mehr mit der Ukraine
zusammen das Unrecht von damals muss
halt solches benannt und aufgearbeitet
werden und das heißt für unsere Politik
heute lassen Sie uns die Ukraine wie zum
Antrag steht als
Opfer der imperialistischen Politik
Wladimir Putins weiterhin politisch
finanziell humanitär und militärisch
unterstützen vielen Dank
stellvertretendefektionsvorsitzende der
SPD-Fraktion Gabriela heinrich war das
und für die afd-fraktion spricht nun
Markierungen
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
der Holodomor Ukrainisch für Massenmord
durch Hunger ist eines der großen
Menschheitsverbrechen des 20
Jahrhunderts Lenin hat es 1922 bereits
angekündigt wir werden noch den Terror
einschließlich des wirtschaftlichen
Terrors verwenden den exekutierte dann
Stalin in unfassbarer Brutalität die
zwangskollektivierten Kulaken also die
den Kommunisten verhassten
selbstständigen Bauern wurden 19323 in
der ganzen Sowjetunion zu unerfüllbar
hohen Abgaben verpflichtet wer sich
nicht fügte dem Namen bewaffnete
Kommandos die gesamte Ernte und
sämtliche Lebensmittelvorräte Weg die
Ukraine ausgerechnet die Kornkammer
Europas traf es besonders hart auch weil
Stalin das dortige Nationalbewusstsein
eliminieren wollte
das Land wurde abgeriegelt Bahnfahrten
war nicht mehr erlaubt bis zu vier
Millionen Menschen wurden dem sicheren
Hungertod ausgeliefert wenn wir heute an
dieses monströse Verbrechen erinnern
dann muss die Lehre doch vor allem eines
sein die sozialistische Ideologie mit
ihrem Hass auf Individualität und
Freiheit mit ihrem gleichmachungsterror
und ihrem waren einen neuen Menschen
schaffen zu können ist abzulehnen und zu
bekämpfen wo immer sie in neuer
Verkleidung ihr freundliches Haupt
erhebt
das gilt für die
nationalsozialistische Variante aber es
gilt eben auch für die internationale
Variante die sich hinter sowohl
klingenden Parolen wie Gerechtigkeit
oder Fortschritt versteckt die
afd-fraktion hat bereits vor drei Jahren
über den Holodomor hier im Deutschen
Bundestag informiert damals hat es kaum
jemanden interessiert bei Verbrechen im
kommunistischen Machtbereich hat unser
linkslastiges politisches System
Engagement jahrzehntelang lieber
weggeschaut man kommt ja auch bei dem
Gedenken an die SED-Verbrechen nicht
recht voran das Mahnmal ist noch immer
nicht gebaut der engagierte Leiter der
Gedenkstätte Hohenschönhausen wurde
elegant absolviert und so weiter warum
ist den gleichen politischen Kräften die
Erinnerung an den Holunder jetzt
plötzlich so wichtig
wir fürchten aus schiefen Gründen in
ihrem reden hier und ja auch in den
sonstigen Verlautbarungen findet eine
starke Parallelisierung und teils ja
schon fast eine in Einsetzung der
historischen Ereignisse mit dem heutigen
Krieg Russlands gegen die Ukraine statt
die Heidelberger Historikerin Tanja
pentner spricht dem Spiegel sehr zurecht
von einer unglücklichen Verflechtung
separater historischer Kontext der in
ihrem Antrag und die genozidforscherin
Christin platt warnt in Deutschlandradio
Kultur mit dem Begriff des Genozids oder
Völkermords muss man sehr vorsichtig
umgehen denn gerade im Krieg mit der
häufig strategisch und auch
propagandistisch eingesetzt Zitat Ende
übrigens hat auch Wladimir Putin die
Ukraine des Völkermords an den Russen in
den Ostprovinzen bezichtigt wir sollten
die Maßlosigkeit solcher Vorwürfe hier
im Westen nicht spiegeln meine Damen und
Herren
aber die deutsche Politik berauscht sich
wie üblich am Hochgefühl ihrer
moralischen Überlegenheit
Außenministerin bärburg spricht mit
Blick auf Russlands Kriegsführung die
bisher laut un-statistik Grund 6.500
zivile Opfer gefordert hat jetzt sogar
von einem Zivilisationsbruch ein
Ausdruck der sonst dem Holocaust
vorbehalten ist Frau beerburg wo immer
sie heute sind eine weiße Staatsführung
zeigt sich gerade in einer Krise nicht
in maximaler rhetorischer Eskalation
sondern in Maß und Umsicht mit Blick auf
den Frieden den sie im Auge behalten
sollten beides lassen sie eklatant
vermissen und noch einen Irrtum von
ihnen möchte ich hier zum Abschluss
korrigieren die Ukrainer die jetzt mit
der Waffe in der Hand und vielleicht mit
der Erinnerung an den Holodomor im
Herzen ihre Heimat verteidigen sie tun
es nicht für die Werte des
internationalen Regenbogens für
diversity Toleranz und Gleichstellung
sie tun es für die Souveränität ihr
Landes für den Erhalt ihres Volkes und
ihrer Kultur darin haben Sie unsere
Solidarität an den hollodomorr ist auch
zu erinnern aber die
Instrumentalisierung der Geschichte die
sie betreiben lehnen wir vielen Dank
war das für die
afd-fraktion im Anschluss an diese
Debatte werden die Abgeordneten direkt
dann auch über diesen Antrag abstimmen
Ulrich Lechte spricht nun als nächstes
erst ob man im Auswärtigen Ausschuss für
die Liberalen in deutschen Parlament
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Exzellenzen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die manitan
aber in Wagner und Knut Abraham meinen
Dank für den exzellenten Antrag wir
wollen im Deutschen Bundestag heute
erinnern mahnen und gedenken dem
grausamen Verbrechen des holodomorts
damit geben wir einer der größten
humanitären Katastrophen des 20
Jahrhunderts die Öffentlichkeit die sie
verdient
Stalins geplanter und begangener
Massenmord in der Ukraine ist ein
Menschheitsverbrechen das bis in die
späten 80er Jahre von Russland
bestritten und vor der Weltgemeinschaft
verborgen wurde
ausgerechnet heute wird es dort erneut
geleugnet
über drei Millionen Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer sind im holodumor in den Jahren
1932 und 33 zum Opfer gefallen davon
betroffen war nicht nur Bauern aus den
Getreide produzierenden Regionen sondern
jede Familie in der gesamten Ukraine war
davon betroffen es war eine
unvorstellbare Strafe für den Widerstand
der Ukraine gegen die sowjetische
Zwangskollektivierung und für ihre
Ablehnung der sowjetischen Herrschaft
mit der Vernichtung der ukrainischen
Kultur Sprache und Traditionen sollte
der Völkermord letztlich vollzogen
werden
gemäß der Definition handelt sich bei
einem Völkermord um einen gezielten
Versuch eine Nation zumindest teilweise
zu eliminieren im Falle des holodomore
ergibt sich die Tötungsabsicht eindeutig
aus der Beschlagnahmung von
Nahrungsmitteln und der bewussten
Blockade der hungergebiete Menschen
wurden erschossen weil sie Lebensmittel
besaßen
insofern möchten wir hier und heute die
Gelegenheit nutzen und nochmals klar
betonen aus historisch politischer
Perspektive handelte sich beim
hollodumor um Völkermord
es war
ein menschenverachtendes Verbrechen das
von Stalin und seinen Schergen politisch
gewollt künstlicher beigeführt und
systematisch durchgeführt wurde die
Beschäftigung mit der Vergangenheit
macht einen fassungslos und lässt
tränenfließen und erneut ist die Ukraine
Ziel unglaublicher Verbrechen denn
werden 1932 respektive 33 nur wenig nach
außen drang sind wir als
Weltöffentlichkeit gegenwärtig Zeuge der
russischen Kriegsverbrechen und das
erneuten Terrors gegen die ukrainische
Zivilbevölkerung die aktuelle
Kriegsführung Russlands zeigt gewisse
Parallelen der Vergangenheit liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen denn erneut
wird Hunger auch als Waffe eingesetzt
wie sie sich sicherlich erinnern wurde
zu Beginn des russischen angriffskriegs
vierfach Getreide aus der Ukraine
gestohlen
es wurden gezielt Versorgungsketten
unterbrochen und fluchtkorridore für die
Zivilbevölkerung bombardiert
mittlerweile nutzt Putin vermehrt Kälte
und Dunkelheit als Kriegsmittel um
unseren europäischen Partner die Ukraine
pausenlos unter Druck zu setzen und in
den russisch besetzten Gebieten wir mit
erneut auch Hunger als Mittel gegen die
dortige Bevölkerung eingesetzt all dies
um die russische mehr von der
entenazifizierung der Ukraine aufrecht
zu erhalten die ukrainische Bevölkerung
zu brechen und ihnen ihre staatliche
Souveränität zu nehmen doch damit meine
Damen und Herren ist schon Stalin vor 90
Jahren gescheitert und für mich steht
zweifelsfrei fest dass auch
putinenschalter wird
die Ukraine
die Ukraine wird diesen Krieg nicht
verlieren die Ukraine wird als Nation
Fortbestehen als unabhängiger
demokratischer Staat das ist nicht
verhandelbar dabei werden wir Sie auch
weiterhin mit allen Möglichkeiten
unterstützen das habe ich den
ukrainischen Botschafter in einem
persönlichen Gespräch versichert mit dem
von uns eingebrachten Antrag wird der
Völkermord in das damit verbundenen
massenhafte ukrainische Leid anerkannt
gleichzeitig wollen wir mit dem Antrag
zum historischen Verständnis beitragen
und den russischen
Geschichtsrevisionismus im Keim
ersticken vor dem Hintergrund des
völkerrechtswidrigen russischen Bomben
teros gegen unschuldige Zivilisten und
zivile Infrastruktur ist jetzt die Zeit
Farbe zu bekennen für die Ukraine die
auch für unser aller Freiheit kämpft
Putins Ansinnen die Ukraine von der
Landkarte zu tilgen wird scheitern sein
Angriff gegen die Freiheit und
Demokratie unseres Westens wird